some examples.
The first thing you need is
data.
You may want to validate results
or test ideas on a common public
dataset.
It includes a large and rapidly
growing collection of datasets
you can get
started with easily and combined
with tf.data it is simple to
wrap your own data too. Here is
a small sample of the datasets
available and all of these and
many nor are included there.
Then with Keras, you can express
the
models just like you are used to
thinking about it.
Standard package is fit with
model fit and evaluate as well.
Since deep learning models are
often
commutationally expensive you
way want
to try scaling this across more
than one device.
Starting from a pre-trained
model or component also works
well to reduce some
of this computational cost.
TensorFlow helps provide a large
collection of pretained
components you
can include in your model and
Feinstein
-- fine tune for your dataset.
Keras comes with everything you
might need for a typical
training job.
Sometimes you need a bit more
control. For example when you
are exploring new kinds of
algorithms.
Let's say you wanted to build a
custom
encoder for machine translation,
here is
how you could do this by
subclassing the model.
You can even customize it
training loop
to get full control over the
gradients
and optimization process.
While training models, whether
packaged with Keras or more
complex ones, it is often
valuable to understand the
progress and even analyze the
muddle in detail.
TensorFlow board provides a lot
of visualization to help with
chis and
comes full integration with
Colab and
other Jupyter notebooks allowing
you to
see the same visuals. All of
these features are available in
TensorFlow 2.0 and I am really
excited to announce
our alpha release is available
for you as of today.
[Applause]
Many of you in the room and
across the world really helped
with lots of work to make this
possible. I would really like to
take this moment to thank you
you all. Please give yourself a
round of applause.
We really couldn't have done
this
without you.
In addition to all the great
improvements we talked about,
this
release comes with a converter
script
and compatibility module to give
you
access to the 1.X APIs. We are
working for a full release over
the next quarter.
There is a lot of work going on
to make TensorFlow 2.0 work well
for you. You can track the
progress and provide
feedback on the TensorFlow
GitHub projects page.
You asked for better
documentation, and
we have worked to streamline our
docs
for APIs, guides and tutorials.
All of this material will be
available
today on the newly redesigned
TensorFlow.org website where you
will find examples,
documentation and tools to get
started. We are very excited
about these changes and what's
to come. To tell you more about
improvements in TensorFlow for
research and production, I would
like to welcome Megan Kacholia
on stage.
Thank you.
Thank you. Thanks Rajat.
TensorFlow has always been a
platform for research to
production.
We just saw how TensorFlow
high-level APIs make it easy at
a get started and build models
and now let's talk about
how it improves experimentation
for research and let's you take
models from
research and production all the
way through. We can see this in
paper publications
which are shown over the past
few years in this chart.
Powerful experimentation begins
and
really needs flexibility and
this begins with eager execution
and TensorFlow 2.0 every Python
command is immediately executed.
This means you can write your
code in
the style you are used it
without having to use session
realm. This makes a big
difference in the realm of
debugging.
As you iterate through, you will
want
to distribute your code on to
GPUs and
TPUs and we have provided tf.
function turning your eager code
into a graph
function-by-function. You get
Python control flow, asserts and
even print but can convert to a
graph any time you need to,
including when you are ready to
move your model into production.
Even with this, you will
continue to get great debugging.
Debugability is great not just
in eager
but we have made improves in tf.
function and graph. Because of
the mismatch inputs you get an
error.
As you can see, we give
information to
user about the file and line
number where the error occurs.
We have made the error messages
concise, easy to understand and
actionable. We hope you enjoy
the changes and they make it
easier to progress with the
models. Performance is another
area we know researchers as well
as all users for that matter
care about. We have continued
improving core performance in
TensorFlow. Since last year, we
have sped up
training on eight Nvidia
TeslaV100s by LLGS double.
With Intel and MKL acceleration
we have gotten inference speed
up by almost three times.
Performance will continue to be
a focus of TensorFlow 2.
0 and a core part of our
progress to final release.
TensorFlow also provides
flexibility
and many add on libraries that
expand and extend TensorFlow.
Some are extensions to make
certain
problems easier like tf.text
with Unicode.
It helps us explore how we can
make machine learning model
safer by a tf.privacy. You will
hear new announcements on
reinforcement learning and
tomorrow we
will discuss the new tf.
federated library.
It is being applied to real
world applications as well.
Here are a few examples from
researchers at Google where we
see it applied to areas like
data centers and making them
more efficient. Our apps like
Google Maps, the one in
the middle, which has a new
feature
called global localization and
combines street service.
And devices like the Google
Pixel that use machine learning
to improve depth estimation to
create better portrait mode
photos like the ones shown here.
In order to make these real
world applications a reality,
you must be able
to take models from research and
prototyping to launch and
production. This has been a core
strength and focus for
TensorFlow. Using TensorFlow you
can deploy models on a number of
platforms shown here and models
end up in a lot of places so we
want to make sure TensorFlow
works across all these servers,
Cloud, mobile,
edge devices and Java and number
of platforms.
We have products for these.
TensorFlow Extended is the end
the end platform.
In orange, shown here, you can
see the
libraries we have Open
SourceSourced so far. We are
taking a step further and
providing components built from
these libraries that make up an
end-to-end platform. These are
the same components used
internally in thousands of
production systems powering
Google's most important
products. Components are only
part of there story.
2019 is the year we are putting
it together and providing you
with an integrated end-to-end
platform.
You can bring your own
orchestrator.
Here is airflow or raw
Kubernetes even.
Not matter what orchestrate you
chose, the items integrate with
the metadata store.
This enables experiments,
experimentation, experiment
tracking and model comparison
and things I am sure you will be
excited about and will help you
as you iterate through. We have
an end-to-end talk coming up
from Clemens and his team and
they will
take you on a complete tour of
TensorFlow Extended to solve a
real problem. TensorFlow Lite is
our solution for
running models on a mobile and
IOt hardware.
On device models can be
reore responsive and keep users
on device for privacy.
Google and partners like
iqiyi provide all sorts of
things. TensorFlow Lite is about
performance.
You can deploy models to CPU,
GPU, and even EdgeTPU.
By using the latest techniques
and adding support for OpenGL
and metal on
GPUs and tuning performance on
EdgeTPUs we are constantly
pushing the limits of what is
possible. You should expect
greater enhancements in the year
ahead.
We will hear details from Raziel
and colleaguess coming up later.
JavaScript is the number one
programming laj  language in the
world
and until recently hasn't
benefited from
all the machine learning tools.
We released TensorFlow.js last
year.
Since then we have seen huge
adoption in the JavaScript
community with more
than 300,000 downloads and a 100
contributors. We are just at the
beginning given how
big the JavaScript ecosystem is.
Today we are excited to announce
TensorFlow.js 1.0.
We have a library of off the
shell models for common ML
problems and we
have adding support for more
platforms
where jafs runs and a huge focus
in TensorFlow.js is on
performance improvements.
Compared to last year, mobile
net
inference and browser is now
nine times faster. You will
learn more about these advances
in our talk later in the day.
Another language we are excited
about is Swift.
It is reexamining what it means
for performance and usability.
With a new programming model, it
intends to bring further
usability. We are announcing
Swift for TensorFlow is now at
0.2 and ready for you to
experiment with,
try out and we are really
excited to be bringing this to
come community.
In addition to telling you about
version 0.
2 we are excited to announce
Jeremy Howard of fast.ai is
writing a new course and Chris
and Brennan will tell you a lot
more about this later today.
To recap everything we have
shown you,
TensorFlow has grown to a full
Eco
system from research to
production from server to
mobile. This growth has been
fuelled by there community and
wouldn't be possible without the
community.
To talk about what we are
planning for you and with you in
2019, I will hand it over to
Kemal.
[Applause]
Thank you, Megan.
Hi, may name is Kemal and I am
the product director. We are
celebrating the most important
part of what we are building and
that is the community.
I love building developer
platforms.
I used to be a developer and now
I
enable developers by building a
better platplatform. We turned
to the community and consulted
with all of you on important
product decisions.
We received valuable feedback
and couldn't have built 2.0
without you.
We created special interest
groups, or
SIGs, like networking and
TensorBoard to name a few.
SIGs are a great way to build
the pieces of TensorFlow they
care the most about. We wanted
to hear more about what you
were building and launched the
power by TensorFlow campaign.
We were amazed by the creativity
of the
products. After three years, our
community is really thriving.
There are 70 machine learningGD
Es
around the world, 1800
contributors and countless more
doing amazing work to help make
TensorFlow successful.
On behalf of the whole
TensorFlow team
we want to say a huge thank you.
[Applause]
We have big plans for 2019 and I
would like to make a few
announcements.
First, as our community grows,
we welcome people who are new to
machine
learning and it is really
important to provide them with
the best educational material.
We are excited to announce two
new online courses. One is with
deeplearning.ai and published in
the Coursera
platform and the other is with
Udacity. The first batch of the
lessons is available right now
and provide an awesome
introduction to TensorFlow for
developers. They require no
prior knowledge to machine
learning.
I highly encourage you to check
them out.
Next, if you are a student for
the very first time, you can
apply to the Google summer of
code program and get to work
with the TensorFlow engineering
team to
help build a part of TensorFlow.
I also talked about the power by
TensorFlow campaign.
We are excited and decided to
launch a 2.0 hackathon on
DevPost to let you share
your latest and greatest and win
cool prizes. We are really
excited to see what you are
going to build.
Finally, as our ecosystem grows,
we are having a second day of
the summit, but we really wanted
to do something more. We wanted
a place where you can share what
you have been building on
TensorFlow.
So we are excited to announce
TensorFlow World.
A week long conference dedicated
to open source collaboration.
This conference will be
co-presented by O'Rielly media
and TensorFlow and held in Santa
Clara at the end of October. Our
vision is to bring together the
awesome TensorFlow World and
give a place for folks to
connect with each other.
I would like to invite on stage
Gina Blaber to say a few words
about the conference.
[Applause]
Thank you, Kemal.
O'Rielly is a learning company
with a focus on technology and
business. We have strong ties
with the open source community
as many of you know,
and we have a history of
bringing big ideas to life.
That's why we are excited about
partnering with TensorFlow to
create this new event that
brings machine
learning and AI to the
community.
The event is TensorFlow
happening October 28th-31 in
Santa Clara. When I say
community, I mean everyone.
We want to bring together the
entire TensorFlow community of
individuals and teams and
enterprises. This is it place
where you will meet experts from
around the world, the team that
actually creates TensorFlow, and
the companies and enterprises
that will help you deploy it.
We have an open CFP on the
TensorFlow World site. I invite
you all to check it out and send
in your proposals soon so your
voice is heard at that event. We
look forward to seeing you at
TensorFlow World in October.
Thank you.
[Applause]
Thank you, Gina. This is going
to be great.
Are you guys excited?
So we have a few calls to action
for you.
Take a course, submit a talk to
TF World. The grand prize for
hackathon on DevPost will
include free tickets to
TensorFlow World. You know, one
thing I love is to hear about
these amazing stories of people
building awesome stuff on top of
TensorFlow.
As a team, we really believe
that AI advances faster when
people have access to our tools
and can then apply them to
the problems they care about in
ways that we never really
dreamed of. And when people can
really do that, some special
things happen. I would like to
share when you something really
special.
Looking at this book, page by
page, and
trying to decipher, read and
transcribe whatever is there
takes an enormous amount of
time.
It would require an army army
polyographer.
Machine learning enabled us to
solve
problems that up to 10-15 years
ago we
thought were unsolvable.
You have thousands of images of
dogs and cats in the internet
but very little
images of ancient manuscripts.
We involved high school students
to collect the data. I didn't
know much about machine
learning in general, but I found
it easy to create a TensorFlow
environment.
When we were trying to figure
out which model worked best for
us, Keras was the best solution.
The production model runs on
TensorFlow
layers and estimator interface.
We experimented with binary
classification with fully
connected
networks and finally we moved to
convolutional neural networks
and classification.
When it comes to recognizing
single
characters, we can get 95%
average accuracy.
This will have an enormous
impact.
We will have a massive quantity
of historic information
available.
I think solving problems is fun.
It is a game against myself and
how good I can do.
That is --
[Applause]
This is such a great story.
I think about the scholars who
wrote
these manuscripts, they cannot
have
imagined centuries later people
bringing their work to life.
We are thrilled to have
Elena. The team and I will be
around. Come and say hi. With
that, I am going to hand it over
to Martin who will talk about
TensorFlow 2.0. Thank you.
Thank you, Kemal. I am Martin
Wicke.
I am the engineer lead for
TensorFlow 2.
0 and I will unsurprisingly talk
about TensorFlow 2.0. TensorFlow
has been extremly successful and
inside of Google and outside of
Google it has grown into a
vibrant community that when we
started it we were not able to
imagine.
Our users are building these
engenous,
clever, elegant things every day
from
art to music to medieval
manuscripts, science and
medicine.
The things people created were
unexpected and beautiful. We
learned a lot from that.
We learned a lot from how people
did it.
TensorFlow has enabled all this
creativity and jump started this
whole
AI democraization which is
great.
It has been hard to use
sometimes. Sometimes a little
bit painful.
So, you know, using sessions
wasn't the
most natural thing to do when
coming from regular Python. The
TensorFlow API has grown over
time. It got a little bit
cluttered and confusing. In the
end, you can do everything with
TensorFlow, but it wasn't maybe
always clear what was the best
way.
We have learned a lot since we
started this and we reallyized
that you need rapid prototyping
and easier debugging. There is a
lot of clutter. So, we are
fixing this, addressing these
issues with a new version of
TensorFlow.
Today, we are releasing an alpha
of TensorFlow 2.0. Many of you
have participated in the
design reviews that went into
this for all the features we
have blended. Those of you
living on the bleeding edge of
development have played it with,
installed it, tested it, found
issues and fixed issues. Thank
you very much for your help.
You can now install the alpha
release of TensorFlow 2.
0 using just pip install
pre-TensorFlow and you can go
and play with it. What has
changed?
When we created TensorFlow 2.
0, the biggest flow was
flexibility. We have integrated
Keras with TensorFlow. It gives
you a path of how to develop
and deploy models and has a well
established API that makes
people productive and we know it
gets you started quickly.
TensorFlow also includes a
complete implementation of
Keras, of course, but we went
further. We have extended Keras
so that you can
use all of the advanced features
in
TensorFlow directly from
tf.Keras.
The other change is eager
execution.
It used declarative style and
was distance from running
Python. In TensorFlow 2.
0, TensorFlow
behaves just like
the Python style. All of that
stuff is not going away.
It is just getting easier.
TensorFlow 2.0 is a major
release which means we have
the ability to clean it up and
we did, like a lot. We had a lot
of duplicate functionality we
have removed.
We have consolidated the API and
organized the API. This is not
only with TensorFlow itself
but the whole ecosystem of tools
that has grown around
TensorFlow. We have spent a lot
of effort to align these
interfaces and defined exchange
formats that will allow you to
move all throughout this
ecosystem without hitting any
barriers. We have removed a lot
of stuff from TensorFlow but it
doesn't mean -- it
means that it has gotten more
flexible not less. It retains
and expands on the flexibility
and we have created a more
complete low level API that
exposes all
of the internal used ops to the
user.
We provide inheritable
interfaces for
the crucial concepts like
variables and checkpoints.
This allows framework authors to
build
on top of TensorFlow and
maintain
interoperability with the rest
of the ecosystem.
There will be a talk about tf.
agents later and Sonnet by
DeepMind tomorrow. You will see
how this works in practice. The
real question is of course what
do
I have to do be apart of this
great new era of TensorFlow and
we know it is
always hard to upgrade to
anything and that is especially
true for major up grades. We
will start the process of
converting one of the largest
codebases in the world to
TensorFlow 2.0 and we will be
writing a lot of migration
guides. We have started already
and some are
online and will provide a lot of
best practices for you. If we
can do it at Google, you can
probably do it too. We are
giving you, and us, a lot of
tools to make this transition
easier.
We are shipping a module called
tf.contrib which contains all of
the complex API. If you rely on
a specific function you
can find it there except for tf.
contrib which isn't going to be
included but we have created a
community supported alternative
that support your use case if
you are relying on something in
there.
We are also publishing a script
which automatically updates your
code so it runs on TensorFlow
2.0. Let me show you how that
works. Let's say I want to
convert this
program which is a simple
language model chain of
Shakespeare.
What where do is run  TF upgrade
2. There is just a handful of
things it changed in this case.
You can see, if you look at what
it changed, there is some
functions it renamed.
A lot of the reorganization of
the API.
It renamed multi nomial to
random
categorical. A lot had functions
changed or added and deleted.
The script will make those
changes.
If all else fails, there is not
an equivalent and we will use
the compatibility module I
talked about earlier.
If there is no perfect
replacement, we will use that to
make sure your code still works
as expected after the
conversion. It is pretty
conservative.
For instance, the atom optimizer
is a subtle behavior change that
will mostly not affect you but
we will convert that just in
case it might. Once the
conversion is complete, and
there are no errors, then you
can run the new program against
TensorFlow 2.0 and it will work.
That's the idea. It should be
pretty easy for you. Hopefully
you won't get trouble. Note that
this automatic conversion
will fix it so it WOSH works but
won't fix the style to the new
TensorFlow 2.0 style.
That can not be done
automatically and
there is a lot more to know.
If you want to know more, check
out the
talk at 10:30 tomorrow. Let me
give you an idea about the
timeline of all this. We have
cut 2.0 alpha today or
yesterday.
Took some time building it. We
are now working on implementing
some missing features that we
know about, converting
libraries, converting Google.
There is lots of testing and
optimization that will happen
and we are targeting to have a
release candidate in spring.
Spring is a flexible concept but
in spring.
After we have this release
candidate, it still has to go
through release testing and
integration testing.
I expect that to take longer
than regular releases but that
is one you can see an RC and
eventually a final. So, if you
want to follow along with the
process, please, do so.
All of this is tracked online on
the GitHub TensorFlow 2.0
tracker.
If you file any bugs, those are
up there
as well so everybody knows what
is going on.
TensorFlow 2.0 really wouldn't
be possible without you. That
has been the case already but in
the future even more so. We will
need you to test this, we will
need you to tell us what works
and doesn't. Please install the
alpha today. We are extremely
excited to see what you can
create. Check out the docs.
They are at tensorflow.org/r2.0.
With that, I think you should
hear about what it is like to
work with TensorFlow 2.0. We
will have plenty of content over
the next couple days to tell you
exactly about all the different
aspects of it
but we will start with Karmel
who will speak about high-level
APIs in
TensorFlow
2.0.thank you.
Hi,  my name is Karmel Allison.
Martin just told you about
TensorFlow 2.0 and how to get
there and I will tell you a
little bit more about the
high-level APIs.
What do I mean when I say
high-level APIs? With our
high-level APIs, we bring you
tools to help you easily build
your models and scale them.
As Martin mentioned, a couple
years ago, TensorFlow adopted
Keras as one of the high level
APIs we offered. Keras is a
specification for model bidding.
It works with multiple machine
learning frameworks and it
provides a shared
language for defining layers,
models,
losses, optimizers and so on.
We
implemented tf.Keras. Raise your
hand if you are used this? Keras
is just that. Simple.
It was built from the ground up
to be
Pythonic and easy to learn and
has been instrumental in
inviting people into the machine
learningworld.
It is easy for you to design and
modify your model architectures
without needing
to write tons of boilerplate. At
the same time, by replying on
inheritance and interfaces,
Keras is
extremely flexible and
customizeable.
I can define architectures,
modify what happens and even
change the whole training loop,
if I want to.
Which is to say Keras is simple
and effective.
Anyone can figure out how to use
it but we had a problem. Tf.
Keras was built for smaller
problems and many machine
learning need to operate at a
larger scale. We have
estimators.
They were built from the ground
up to
distribute and scale with fault
tolerance across hundreds of
machines no questioned asked.
This is the much love wide and
deep model.
A work horse that took mean
years to
define but is a built-in for
training and deployment.
Estimators are powerful machines
but you told us there is a steep
learning curve and it is not
always easy to figure out which
parts to connect where. We have
learned a lot building estimator
and tf.Keras and reached the
point we don't
think you should have to chose
between a simple API and
scalable API.
We want a higher level API
taking you from endness to plan
and scale, no questions asked.
In TensorFlow 2.0, we are
standardizing on the Keras API
for building layers and models
but
bringing the power estimators
into tf.Keras so you can move
from prototype, distributes
training and production serving
in one go.
OK. How are we doing this? This
is a tf.
Keras model definition in
TensorFlow 1.13.
This is the same model
definition in 2.0.
The code is the same but what is
different? In 1.13 this built a
graph-base model that ran a
session under the hood. In 2.
0, the same model runs in eager
mode without any modification.
This let's you take advantage of
everything eager can do for us.
We see our dataset pipeline
behaves like a num
py array. We are able to achieve
this performance with datasets
and Keras by taking advantage of
graphs even in an eager context.
Eager makes debugging and
prototyping
easy and all the while Keras
builds an eager-friendly
function under the hood that
tracks your model and the
TensorFlow Runtime takes care of
optimizing for performance and
scaling. You can explicitly run
your model in eager mode with
the flag run eagerly even though
for this example it might be
overkill, you can see run
eagerly allows you to use Python
control flow for
debugging while prototyping your
model.
Another big change in TensorFlow
2.
0 is we have consolidated many
headings
and maing it easier to know what
you should use and when.
We have one set of optimizers
that work
across TensorFlow in and out of
eager
mode on one machine or
distributed.
You can set opt amam --
optimizers.
We have one set of metrics that
encompasses all the former tf.
metrics and Keras metrics and
allow for
easy subclassing if you want
even more.
Losses, similarly, have been
consolidated into a single set
with a number of frequency used
built-ins and an easily
customizeable interface if you
chose. We have one set of layers
built in the style of Keras
layers which means they
are class based and
fully configureconfiguable. One
set of layers that we took
particularly care with were the
RNN layers in TensorFlow.
Raise your hand if you are used
RNN layers in TensorFlow?
These slides are for you. In
TensorFlow version 1 we had
several
versions of
LSTMs and GRUs. In 2.0, there is
one version of the LSTM
layer and one version of the
gru level.
This runs the kernel but falls
back to
CPU ops if you don't have GPUs
available. In addition to all of
those, if you
need layers that are not
included in the
built in set, tf.
Keras provides a subclass that
is easy to customize. This is
how TensorFlow addons operate
providing specialized and
complex layers, metrics, and so
on by building
on top of the Keras base
classes.
We streamlined APIs. That is a
start.
The next thing we did was
integrate.
We found easily configurable
data parsing. In TensorFlow 2.
0, you can use Feature Columns
to parse data and feed directly
to downstream layers.
This works with Keras and
estimators so you can mix and
match to create reusable data
input pipelines. OK. You have
data in your model and you are
ready to train.
One of the most loved tools we
have is TensorBoard and I am
pleased to see TensorBoard
integration with Keras is as
simple as one line.
We have the TensorBoard callback
to our model when training here
and this gets us both our
training progress, here we
see accuracy and loss, and a
conceptual graph representing
the model we built layer by
layer.
As an add in bonus, it includes
full callback so you can better
understand
the placement and find ways to
minimize bottlenecks. Speaking
of performance, one of the
exciting pieces we are bringing
TensorFlow 2.
0 is the -- these APIs have been
designed to be easy to use, out
of the box performance and be
versetle. How do they work?
With Keras, you can add and
switch distribution patterns
with a to a lines of code.
We are distributing this across
multiple GPUs.
Because we have integrated
distribution strategies
throughout Keras and TensorFlow
you get a lot with these few
lines of code.
Data is prefetched batch by
batch and mirrored in sync using
all reduce and we see greater
than 90% scaling
efficiencies meaning you can
scale your model up without
changinging code and without
loosing any of the conveniences
of Keras. Once you have trained
your model, you are likely going
to want to package it for use
with production systems, mobile
phones or other programming laj
-- language.
This functionality is
experimental but today and going
into 2.0 you can easily export
your models for use with tf.
serving, tf.lite and more.
You can reload the models back
into that
you be Python to continue
training and using in your
normal workflow. That is where
we are today in the alpha.
We are obviously not done yet.
Let me tell you a little bit
about what is coming up in the
next few months.
We talked about distributing
over multiple GPU but that is
just the start.
We can swap out strategy and
scale up to multiple nodes.
Here we cake the same Keras
model and distribute it across
multiple machines
working in sync using collective
ops.
The multi-worker mirror strategy
supports Ring and allows great
performance.
You can try it out today. If you
are interested in a TensorFlow
native solution to synchronous
multi working training. We are
excited to say using Keras and
distribute strategies you will
be able
to use the same code to
distribute models on TPUs. When
released, this strategy will
work
on Google Cloud
TPUs and Colab which can access
TPUs directly. As we approach
the final 2.0 release we will
continue to bring scalability
into Keras and allow parameter
service strategy, the multi
node asynchronous training that
estimator does today.
For those that want a higher
level API, we will be adding
support for partition variables
across many machines for some
of the largest scale models like
those we run at Google.
And that's just a sneak peek so
please check out the 2.
0 preview and check out Keras if
you haven't already.
You will hear more about Keras
and high-level APIs throughout
the day and
we have a workshop tomorrow that
Martin mentioned.
With that, let me introduce
Raziel who
will tell you more about TFLite.
Thanks, Karmel. Hi, everyone.
My name is Raziel and I am an
engineering lead.
Today I will be covering at  --
a lot of the work the team has
done
over the past year that you can
take advantage of right away. I
am cover a lot of work we have
for this year. Before we jump
into that, let me give
you a brief introduction of what
TensorFlow Lite is.
TensorFlow Lite is our
infrastructure framework to run
machine learning on device.
The reason why we decided to
built TensorFlow Lite was
because machine learning you
think of it as running on the
server, but more and more it is
moving to edge devices like
mobile
devices, cars, Wearables, you
name it. There is more machine
learning moving to different
kinds of devices. There is good
reason for that.
One, you have access to a lot
more data
because you have access to the
algorithm, camera, and don't
have to
stream it all the way to the
server so you can do a lot of
stuff.
It means you can build faster
and close-knit interactions.
Another advantage of running
machine
learning on devices is it has a
strong privacy preserving
component because the data stays
on the device and doesn't
have to go to the server.
However, that means basically by
building machine learning on
devices we can build products
that otherwise
wouldn't be able to really work
if you
really rely only on server-side
execution. However, you know, it
is hard. Perhaps one obvious
thing is you don't have the same
compute power you have on the
server. If you have a new shiny
machine learning model that
consumes too much compute power,
it is not like in the server
where you can throw perhaps more
servers at it and be done with
it. You have to be mindful of
the resources that you have on
the device.
Another of those resources is
the memory. You have restricted
memory so you have to be careful
about how you craft your
model, perhaps try some
compression techniques.
Last but not least, many of
these devices are battery
powered and even if you have a
model that fits in memory and
can execute, well, you don't
want to consume all the battery
in a battery powered device.
For all these reasons, we built
TensorFlow Lite and we want to
make deploying machine learning
on edge devices as easily as
possible. What can you do with
it right now? You can do a lot
of things. These are different
tasks that are supported by
TensorFlow Lite already. If you
look at it when you hear machine
learning you typically fall into
one of these tasks. You know,
text-to-speech, image
processing, audio processing, a
lot of
content generation so really,
like, everything is already
there for you to
take advantage of and because we
are already able to support
these tasks, it
means it has a lot of usage
already. TensorFlow Lite is
currently deployed
in over 2 billion devices in
production.
This not only means Google
properties, some of which are
core to Google like
the assistant and Google photos
but come from other large
companies and those are
frameworks.
A lot of our infrastructure is
power
and frameworks.
I can tell you many reasons why
it is a good idea to use our
infrastructure but we thought it
would be best if we bring
two of our component clients to
tell you
how they use TensorFlow Lite.
Our first presenter is Alex
coming from the Google Assistant
which has a wide variety of
devices it is running. Let's
hear why they are using
TensorFlow Lite and how they are
doing.
[Applause]
Thanks, Raziel. I am Alex. I am
an engineering lead on our
embedded speech recognition team
at Google. One of the key
applications for speech
recognition at Google is the
Google Assistant.
Google recently announced the
Google Assistant is on about a
billion devices ranging from
phones, speakers, smart
displays, cars, TVs, laptops,
Wearables,
you name it we are trying to put
the assistant into it. That
means high end devices, low end
devices, battery powered,
plugged in,
and a large range of operating
systems. The neural networks I
build have to be able to run
anywhere.
For assistant, we have a couple
key speech on-device
capabilities. The first is the
hot word.
You need to be able to say
hey, Google to activate the
device and we need to make sure
it is your voice.
We have to have a tiny memory
and
computational input and we are
extremely latency sensitive.
Our other major application is
on device speech recognition. We
use this when you are offline or
have a bad network connection.
Instead of using the server, we
run speech recognition on the
device.
Here we are trying to run large
models as fast as possible to
get the best probably accuracy.
It is an a high load returning
into short burst typically. Over
the years, we have been working
on
this for a long time, before
there was TensorFlow Lite,
before there was TensorFlow, so
we have been investing a
lot for a long time in building
our own on-device neural net
libraries and shipping them to
production in Google product for
a long time.
As a team, we have invested in
keeping
the code size tiny, memory
small, and optimizing for all
different platform and all of
our code after many years
production use is hardened and
as bug-free as you can get it,
hopefully.
Over the last year, we decided
to
migrate to TFLite.
This wasn't an easy decision for
us and
as we switched over we checked
carefully to make sure TFLite
would
beat our existing models and we
have moved all over in the last
year. We are excited because
this lays the
ground work for us moving to a
new standard that is being
widely adopted
and we think TFLite will help us
accelerate models on GPUs and
EdgeTPUs and new accelerators
coming. Thanks.
I will turn it back over to
Raziel.
[Applause]
Thanks, Alex. So, Alex analyzed
the key goals for TensorFlow
Lite.
We want to be able to support
your current-use-cases, but
perhaps equally important or
more important, is we want
to cater to your needs that you
will have 1-2 years in the
future.
Our next presenter is Huiije
from a China-based company that
has several applications and
hundreds of millions of users.
Let's welcome him.
Thanks, Raziel.
I am Huiije from NetEase in
Youdao.
We have built a lot of
dictionary translation and note
taking applications in China.
We have over 800 million users
in total.
We also have 22 million daily
active users.
In the past years, we have built
several dictionary translation
and note taking applications. We
have the most popular dictionary
application in China, for
example, which
is Youdao dictionaries and we
have the
most popular translator in China
and the most popular dictionary
and language
learning application in India
which is Youdao dictionary.
We provide features for users in
these applications so they can
conveniently look up words in
the scenario such as,
for example, you can use your
camera to
recognize the words from the
images and
do the OCR translation on your
devices.
We use the TensorFlow Lite to
use
theOCR and translation here.
We have provided the photo
translation in your
applications.
For example, you can use camera
to take
a photo from the many scenario
and it
will do the whole image of OCR
and
translate the text into another
language.
Then it will erase the text on
the
image and replace the original
text to the translated text to
present users with the
translation.
In this scenario, we also use
the
TensorFlow Lite to accelerate
our OCR
and translation services here.
The OCR and translation is very
sensitive to the binary size and
also
computational resources and
responding time.
So we chose the TensorFlow Lite
to
accelerate our abilities on
device to provide more efficient
on device inference here. That
is why we chose the TensorFlow
Lite to do this. Thanks.
[Applause]
Really exciting to see how our
>> INSTRUCTOR: -- infrastructure
is used
by hundreds of users around the
world. TensorFlow Lite is geared
not only towards Google but
everybody should be able to take
advantage of it.
For the rest of the
presentation, I will cover what
I said at the start.
A lot
of features that are available
over the past year and roadmap
for this year.
We organized our engineering in
four things.
First is usability, overall it
means we want to be able to get
you up and running as easily and
fast as possible.
Now once you have your model
basically we want to get you
executing that model as fast and
possible in the hardware that
you care about.
Then with optimization we look
at certain things we can do to
make it faster and smaller.
Finally, with our documentation
efforts,
we want to give you all the
resources you need. Let's start
with usability. There is
different ways of getting up and
running in TensorFlow Lite but
at
the end of the day you will most
likely
train the model in TensorFlow
and convert it to TensorFlow
Lite. The flow is very simple.
You train in TensorFlow, you get
a
model and use the TensorFlow
Lite convertert and get a model
you can
execute on different kinds of
devices.
However, there is points of
failure. TensorFlow Lite made
the decision to
take a subset of TensorFlow and
optimize those. That means
basically we don't have all the
same hundreds of operations that
TensorFlow has.
The other reason is some
semantics.
We don't support jet on
TensorFlow like
control flow which is typically
used for reoccurring neural
networks.
We have made already like
strides
trying to basically make this
easier and better for you.
Last year we launched TensorFlow
select
and this basically means you can
execute TensorFlow ops in
TensorFlow Lite. In the
pipeline, we are making
improvements to TensorFlow
Select by enabling selective
registration and I will explain
what all this means in the
following slides.
We are working on contraflow
support as well.
Select, like I said, means you
can execute TensorFlow and
TensorFlow Lite. It comes at the
cost of some binary size
increase because right now it is
basically all or nothing, but
that is why we are building
selective registration.
Selective registration is
something you can take advantage
of already on
TensorFlow Lite for our building
ops.
You include in the binary only
the ops you are using. We are
bringing that to TensorFlow
Select.
We are trying to blur the line
of what the TensorFlow and
TensorFlow Lite ops
are and achieve one of the key
points is
blur the performance between one
and the other.
Now, contraflow is something we
are working on.
This is one of fully lighter
pain points
we are trying to convert
occurring neural networks to
TensorFlow Lite. We are adding
supports and loops and
conditionals.
All of this is part of a bigger
effort
to revamp our converter and we
took your feedback very
seriously and we wanted this
converter to answer these three
questions.
Some
Something fails and what went
wrong and what can you do to fix
it. OK. Jumping to the next
theme is performance.
We want your models to execute
as fast
as possible in the hardware you
have available. If you saw in
Megan's slides, we have made
huge slides in these areas.
This is an example of a model.
The execution of the CPU,
floating
point compared to the fast
version in CPU. With the
recently developing preview we
launched, we get huge gains.
Like over 7X improvements.
By using the HTP we get crazy
speed ups. 62X.
Again, this is an area we are
working really hard.
Again, some things that are
already available.
We have a very nice benchmark
and
profiling tool and a few
delegates. For those not
familiar with the concept
of TensorFlow delegates, that is
our abstraction layer that
allows executing
models on the CPU.
In the pipeline we are working
on CPU improvements because we
know CPU is important. I am not
listing here in the pipeline
anything around newer delegates
because it tends to be a
partnership with other companies
and I don't have anything to
announce yet, but we are working
on that.
Our benchmarking tool is
basically a profiler. We added
some features. Personal
threading.
You can see statistics for
opposite execution and it
supports the neural networks
API. If you execute the profiler
you get a lot of information.
This is just a snippet of all
the stuff that you get.
In this case, we are showing you
here information for each op in
your graph and how long it took
to execute. Then you also get a
nice summary of the
archives in your graph and many
useful statistics so you can
decide maybe there
is a way that you can, you know,
change one for another type that
is more efficient or tweak your
graph in some way.
Now let's talk about the
delegates which is an abtraction
layer for extracting graphs.
The way it works is very nice.
In the TensorFlow Lite you
prepare a model, right? You are
not necessarily saying this
model is for this hardware. You
just prepare your model.
Then inpreter will take it and
for those delegates you raised
it will go one by
one and it will say how much of
these graph can you execute.
What the delegate cannot
execute, it
will be executed in CPU.
So, by doing this basically you
will always be able to execute,
right?
And if anything, you will get
better performance if the
delegate can consume more of
your graph.
We have already an
edge-TPU delegate. It has a
small power footprint and
later on we will have more
information
about the edge-TPU and a very
cool demo.
The next delegate is the GPU
delegate. These are available
right now.
We see very nice performance
improvements at the cost of
relatively small binary size
increase.
How do you enable the GPU
delegate?
Just like any other delegate,
this is an example of the
interpreter and executing one
inference.
The only thing you need to do is
share
and pass to interpreter and that
is it. So, stuff that we are
working on for
the
GPU deldelegate, we want to add
more ops.
We want to improve performance
even further.
We want to finalize APIs so this
is generally available.
The final delegate I want to
mention is the neural network
API.
This will allow you to execute
any
other hardware that the API
supports.
It should be just transparent
for you.
Finally, CPU is still very
important for many use-cases.
Most devices have some form of a
CPU.
We are targeting further
improvements
on the arm and X86
architectures.
The
next theme is optimization.
Maybe we can do 2X model to make
it faster and smaller. We
already did some work here.
Last year we released this
quantization tool that gives
nice performance on CPU.
This is the first launch that we
have
while we are calling model
optimization toolkit.
It will be available for use for
everybody.
In the pipeline some of these
new tech
techniques we will put in the
toolkit is more quantization
work.
It gives further improvement on
CPU and allows you to execute
more hardware.
A lot of the hardware like
neural
processing units are fixed point
base
with no floating base support.
We are working on a technique
called production pruning. So
quantization means changing the
precision of your model and how
it is executed on the device.
We launch post training
quantization
tool where you take your save
pod  model
and when you convert to
TensorFlow Lite
you turn on the flag and it
updates.
Trying to get the most
performance and small Keras
loss.
We see nice improvements this
way.
If the model is is fully
quantized and you get 4X.
For convolutional, we see 10-15%
performance improvements but for
fully
connected RNNs we see up to 3X.
This is simple to try. If you
are using TensorFlow Lite or
plan to use it, give this a try.
You have to validate how the
accuracy is
affected in your particular
model but so far we have seen
very good numbers.
Many of the two billion devices
we
mentioned before are running
this way.
In the pipeline, again, we are
making
further improvements in the
quantization approaches that we
have.
We are working on this for
quantization.
We want to make it powerful by
enabling quanterize straining
and easy to use. We are bringing
more post-training quantization
support. This is an example of
Keras model.
It is very easy with two dense
layers.
Let's say you want to train with
quantization those two dense
layers. Well, soon enough, you
will be able to
just import your API and say
quantatize those two layers.
The post-training quantization
for fixed point will work very
much like the one we already
support where you have the
conversion path and the only
thing
you need to parse extra is some
calibration data which is the
typical model your sees as
input. If you have an image
processing model, you just need
to pass some images.
You don't really need to pass a
ton of images. In preliminary
numbers, model Nets, we
see with 25 images we do well.
These are preliminary numbers we
see with this tool.
We have the float baseline and
then if
you do quantization training you
get almost the same accuracy
with all the benefits.
Then even further if you really,
for some reason don't want to
invest in this training or you
have a model, you know,
that you got somewhere, you can
still
quantize it with post training
and you
see the accuracy is almost the
same.
The other technique we are
heavily
investing in is connection
pruning meaning we prune
connections in the
network and those connections
become
Keras and that creates a sparse
tensor.
The benefits of a parse tensor
is you can compress them and
create potentially faster models
if
you have less computations to
do.
Coming very soon, we are going
to add a training pruning as a
Keras-base API and
in the pipeline we are working
on first
class support of this parse
execution in TensorFlow Lite.
Again, in our example from Keras
you
have two dense layers, want to
prune connection from those
layers, and the
only thing you need to do is say
prune. It is very, very simple.
When you convert the model to
TensorFlow Lite format,
basically by
just even seeding the file you
will get nice compressions.
These are some, again, very
preliminary numbers. A mobile
net which is pretty hard to
prune compared to other perhaps
larger
models, we see various models of
50% and even 75%.
Finally, documentation, again,
we want to give you all the
resources you need to get the
most out of TensorFlow Lite.
We have already done pretty nice
improvements.
We have a site with more
content.
We currently have a model
representation with
five models and representations
you can try. We are working on
new models and looking to expand
our repository.
The goal is not only that it is
pretty but that it answers your
questions. Please give us more
feedback if there
is things that are still lacking
there.
Yeah, we revamp the
documentation and
very important, we also have the
roadmap for the foreseeable
future. A lot of the stuff I am
talking about
now you can see there in more
detail perhaps.
And then, again, we have our
repository with all these
applications and tutorials and
we are expanding it. We want to
make the repository into
something that, you know, if you
don't want to go, or before you
start trying to train something,
perhaps you have a
model you can reuse.
By the way, TensorFlow mobile is
aggregated especially using
TensorFlow select allowing you
to use TensorFlow
Lite and there is no need for
TensorFlow mobile except if you
are doing training on the
device. That is the reason we
are keeping that there. Yeah,
training.
So, if you see we are building a
lot of the basic infrastructure
that you will need when you are
trying to prepare a
training pipeline to execute on
device. I don't have anything to
announce now but I just wanted
to let you know that
we are working on it and
thinking a lot about it.
What about TensorFlow 2.0?
Well, it should work.
You should be able to convert it
to TensorFlow Lite. Before we go
two last things. One is there
was a lot of content in this
talk.
Tomorrow we have breakout
sessions and will cover
TensorFlow Lite in general and
optimization in particular.
And I want to introduce Pete
Warden who
is going to talk about some very
cool products.
[Applause]
Awesome.
Thanks so much, Raziel.
I am really excited to be here
to talk
about a new project that I think
is pretty cool. So, TensorFlow
Lite for microcontrollers. What
is that all about? This all
comes back to when I actually
first joined Google back in
2014. There were a whole bunch
of internal projects I didn't
know about as a member
of the public that sort of blew
my mind
but one in particular came about
when I actually spoke to Raziel
for the first time.
He was on the speech team at the
time working with Alex who you
just saw. He explained that they
use neural
networks models of only 13
kilobytes in size. At that time,
I only really had experience
with image networks and the very
smallest of them was still like
multiple megabytes so this idea
of
having a 13 KB model was amazing
for me.
What amazed me even more was
when when he told me why they
had to be so small.
They needed to run them on dsp
and other embedded chips in
smartphones so Android
could listen for wake words like
hey Google while the main CPU
was powered off to save the
battery.
These microcontrollers often
only had 10
kilobytes of RAM and flash
storage.
They couldn't rely on Cloud
connectivity because the amount
of power
that would be drained to send
data over
would have been prohibitive. So,
that really struck me. That
conversation and the continued
work that we did with the speech
team because they had so much
experience doing all sorts of
different approaches with
speech. They had spent a lot of
time and a lot
of energy experimenting and even
within the tough constraints of
embedded devices, neural
networks were better than any of
the traditional method they
used. I was left wondering if
they would be
really useful for other embedded
sensor applications as well and
it left me really wanting to see
if we could actually build
support for these kind of
devices into TensorFlow itself,
so that more people could
actually get access to it. At
the time, only people in the
speech community really knew
about the
groundbreaking work that was
being done
and I wanted to share it a lot
more widely. So, today I am
pleased to announce we are
releasing the first experimental
support for embedded platforms
in TensorFlow Lite.
To show you what I mean, here is
a
demonstration board that I
actually have in my pocket.
This is a prototype of a
development
board built by SparkFun and it
has a
cortex M4 processor with 384
kilobytes
of RAM and a whole MB of flash
storage
and it was built by  to be
extremely low power -- Ambiq.
It is able to run on a single
core battery like this for many
days potentially.
I am going to take my life in my
hands
now by trying a live demo.
Let us see if this is actually
-- it's going to be extremely
hard to
see unless we dim the lights.
There we go.
What I am going to be doing here
is by
saying a particular word and see
if it actually lights up the
little yellow light. You can see
the blue LED is flashing and
that is telling me it is running
inference.
If I try saying
"yessaying "yes", "yes".
I knew I was taking my own life
into my own hands. There we go.
As you can see, it still is far
from perfect but it is managing
to do a job of recognizing when
I say the word and
not lighting up when there is
unrelated conversations. So why
is this useful? Well, first this
is running entirely
locally on the embedded chip, so
we
don't need to have any internet
connection.
It is a good useful first
component of a voice interface
system.
The model isn't quite 13
kilobytes but it is down to 20
kilobytes so it only
takes up 20 kilobytes of flash
storage on this device.
The footprint of the TensorFlow
Lite
for microcontrollers is only
another 25 kilobytes and it only
needs about 30 kilobytes of RAM
to operate. It is within the
capabilities of a lot
of different embedded devices.
Secondly, this is all open
source, so you can actually grab
the code yourself
and build it yourself, and you
can modify it.
I am showing you here on this
particular platform but it
actually works on a
whole bunch of different embeded
chips.
We really want to see lots more
supports so we are keen to work
with the
community on collaboratoring to
get more devices supported. --
collaborating.
You can also train our own
model. Just something that
recognizes yes isn't all that
useful, but the key thing is
that this comes with a toil you
can use to actually train your
own models.
It always comes with a dataset
of
100,000 utterances of about
20,000 common words.
The first link there, if you
could go to that link, and
contribute your voice
to the open dataset, it should
actually increase the size and
the quality of the dataset that
we can actually make available.
That would be awesome. You can
actually use the same approach
to do a lot of different audio
recognition to recognize
different kinds
of sounds and even start to use
it for similar signal processing
problems like,
you know, things like predictive
maintenance. So, how can you try
this out for yourself?
If you are in the audience here,
at the end of today, you will
find that you get
a gift box, and you actually
have one of these in there.
[Applause]
All you should need to do is
remove the little tab between
the battery and it
should automatically boot up
pre-flash with this yes example.
You can try it out for yourself
and let me know how it goes. Say
yes to TensorFlow Lite. We also
include all the cables so you
should be able to program it
yourself through there serial
port.
These are the first 700 boards
ever built so there is a wiring
issue. It will drain the
battery.
It will last more like hours
than days but that will
actually, knock on wood, be
fixed in the final product that
is shipping.
And you should be able to
develop with these in the exact
same way you will with the final
shipping product.
If you are watching at home, you
can pre-order one of these from
SparkFun
right now for, I think, it is
$15.
And you will also find lots of
other
instructions for other platforms
in the documentation.
We are trying to support all of
the -- or as many of the modern
microcontrollers that are out
there that
people are using as possible.
And we welcome collaboration
with everybody across the
community to help unlock all of
the creativity that I know is
out there. I am really hoping I
am going to be spending a lot of
time over the next few
months reviewing pull requests.
And finally, this was my first
hardware
project so I needed a lot of
help from a lot of people
including to TensorFlow
Lite team especially Raziel,
Tim, and
Andy, Allisster, Nathan, owen
and Jim at SparkFun were life
savers.
We got these in our hands in the
middle of the day yesterday.
And also those at Ambiq who
actually designed this process
and helped us get the software
going.
A lot of people are arms as well
including a big shout out to
Neal and Zach. This is a very
early experiment but I can't
wait to see what people build
with this. One final note, I
will be around to
talk about  M CUs with anyone
interested on day two. I am
really looking forward to
chatting with everyone. Thank
you.
[Applause]
Thanks, Pete. We really hope
that you try this.
It is the early stages but you
see a huge help to make this
happen.
We think it will be really
impactful for everybody. Now,
before we go again, and I
promise
this is the last thing you hear
from me,
I want to welcome June, who is
going to
talk about how by use
TensorFlow Lite with the
edge-TPU
delegate are able to train these
usable machines.
[Applause]
Thanks, Raziel. Hi, my name is
June Tate-Gans and I am one of
the lead software engineers
inside Google's new Coral group
and I
have been asked to give a talk
about the
edge-TPU based teachable demo.
Coral is a
platformplatformplatform  for
products with on demand
learning.
Our first product is a single
board
computer and a USB stick. What
is the edge-TPU?
It is a Google designed asic. It
doesn't require a network
connection to run and allows for
a whole new range
of applications and machine
learning.
The first product we built is
the Coral Dev Board.
This is a single board computer
with a removable som. It runs
Linux and Android and the som
has a
gigabyte of ram, Wi-Fi and
Bluetooth and the EdgeTPU.
The second is the corilatored
board connected to whatever
you need be it Raspberry Pi or a
Linux work station.
This teachable machine shows off
a form of edge training.
Traditionally, there is three
ways to do this.
There is K-nearest neighbors,
weight imprinting and last layer
retraining.
For this demo, we are using the
K-nearest neighbors approach.
In this animated GIF, you can
see the TPU enables very high
classification rates. The frame
rate is actually the rate at
which the TPU is classifying the
images that I am showing it. In
this case, you can see we are
getting about 30 frames per
second.
It is essentially real-time
classification.
With that, I actually have one
of our teachable machine demos
here.
If we can turn this on. There we
go. OK.
So, on this board we have our
EdgeTPU development board
assembled with a camera and a
series of buttons. Each button
corresponds with a class and
lights up when the model
identifies
an object from the camera.
First we have to plug this in.
Every time I take a picture, by
pressing one of these buttons it
associates that picture with
that particular class and
because it is
running
inference on the EdgeTPU it
lights up immediately. The first
thing I have to do is train it
on the background. I will press
this blue button and where you
can see it immediately turns on
and
this is because it is doing
inference in realtime.
Now, if I train one of the other
buzz
buttons using something like a
tangerine, you can see it can
classify
between this tangerine and the
background. I can grab other
objects, such as this TensorFlow
Lite sticker. It looks similar.
It is the same color. Let's see
what was the class I used?
Yellow. OK. Sorry.
Now, even though it is a similar
color,
it can still discern the
TensorFlow Lite
logo from the tangerine.
[Applause]
you can imagine in a
manufacturing content, your
operators are no knowledge of
machine learning or training,
can adapt your system easily and
quickly using this exact
technique.
That is about it for the demo
but before I go, I should grab
the clicker
and also I should say, we are
also
giving away some EdgeTPU
accelerators.
For those here today, we will
have one available and for those
on the livestream
you can purchase one at
Coral.Google.com. We also have
links for you up here. Please
take a look at the TensorFlow
Lite and our new hardware and
thank you very much.
[Applause]
Thank you, June. That was
awesome.
So, that is the end of our first
block of talks.
We are now going to have a break
that's about 45 minutes.
We want to be back here by noon.
Sorry we ran a little long.
Thank you for coming up. After
the break, we will be talking
about building models, Swift,
and the community. It is going
to be a lot of great talks.
Go grab something to eat and
come on back here by noon.
Thank you very much.
Tf.
tf.tf.tf.tf.
TF an
TensorFlow 2.
flight 370
TensorFlow Lite
Swift Keras
tf.
touchdown
megabytes
CPU GPU TPU
SIGs
tf.
function function
function TUNGZ
nction
function function tf.function
tf.
function
autograph Alexandre Passos
SIGs SIGs Edd
Swift TensorFlow 2.
FASZ
test test test test
Hello, everyone.
Typhl TIFL TIFL
te
TFLite TFLite
K-nearest
Youdao
Youdao Youdao Youdao
Youdao Youdao
test test test test test
Hi, everyone.
My name is Gal Oshri and I am
here to talk about TensorBoard.
How many have used TensorBoard
before? It helps you visualize a
lot of data coming out of
TensorFlow.
It has a wide variety of
features but
today we will talk about a
couple new additions.
We will actually switch over to
rademo.
This is Colab
.
I made sure we installed
TensorFlow 2.
0 alpha and a couple other sets
so we don't have to install it
now.
We are going to use the dataset
and
train a really simple keras
sequintial model.
We will train it with the fit
API and give it the TensorFlow
callback. If you have used Colab
before, you will
know we will need to download
the logs
to our local machine, make sure
TensorBoard and set-up and point
at it and go back to Colab.
We are enabled showing
TensorBoard directly within
Colab.
You will notice the way we start
TensorBoard here is exactly the
same as in the command line.
It is the same command just as
the magic cell and magic
function in front of it.
The same thing will also work in
Jupyter notebooks.
Let's see what is different.
When using the keras callback we
have trained validation showing
up on the same chart to make it
easier to compare them in
accuracy, loss and other
metrics. This makes it easier to
detect things like overfitting.
In the graph's dashboard, while
seeing
the ops and exillerary
information is
useful for many scenario,
sometimes you want to see the
model you created in keras. So
you can switch to the keras tag
and just few that model.
We can expand this to see the
actual layers we added.
There is several other APIs for
using TensorBoard within
notebooks that let you change
the height of the cell as well
as list the active instances
within your Colab notebook but
we are not going
to look at that because I want
to switch
gears and talk about
hyperparameter training. We
picked the dropout rate, number
of units in the dense layer and
the optimizer.
If we really care about the
modeled's performance we will
want to try out different values
and experiment. The way this
looks in TensorBoard is you
might include all that
information about what the
values are in the run names.
As you can see here
in the bottlebottle -- bottom
left. It is not the best
experience so let's
see if we can do something
better.
What I'm going to show next is
something that is going to
change in terms of the
API and the UI but it is
available in
the TF 2.alpha today. We will do
several different imports and
define which values of the
hyperparameters we want to try.
We will start out with just a
few so we don't take up too much
time during the demo. We are
going to log a summary that
tells TensorBoard what were the
hyperparameters we care about
and what
were the metrics. We then wrap
the existing training code that
we had, just to make sure we
logged the accuracy at the end
on the validation set, and also
tell
TensorBoard that the experiment
has started and finished.
This time we are going to start
TensorBoard before doing our
training because in most cases
your training will take longer
than one minute and you want to
view the TensorBoard while your
model
is training to understand its
progress. We started it.
It has no data but once a couple
epox
of training have finished we can
refresh it and start to see
something.
You will notice in the top we
have the h-parameters dashboard
which show a
table where each run is
represented by a row and we have
columns.
As the runs finish, the table
becomes populated with them. On
the left, we have ability to
filter and sort. We can say we
don't actually care about
the number of units or only want
to see experiments where the
accuracy is at least 85. Before
we proceed further, I want to
actually cheat a little bit and
log and access some completed
experiments where we have run a
wider range of combinations of
values for the hyperparameters.
Now, while this is loading, I
want to
point out that I am pointing
TensorBoard
directly at a folder in my
Google Drive. I had all my
TensorFlow logs on another
machine, uploaded them to my
Google Drive and I can access
them directly within my Colab
notebook. This takes a moment to
load but, hopefully, when I
refresh we can see it.
I can switch over to the
H-parameters dashboard and see
the experience. I can switch
over to this view that
shows the visualization of
access for each hyperparameter
and each metric.
Each run is represented by a
line that
passes through all these axis at
the points corresponding to
hyperparameters and values. I
can click and grab to select a
range. I have selected the
experiments with the relatively
high accuracy and they become
highlighted in this
visualization.
I can immediately see that all
these experiments used the
add-in optimizer as
asupposed to SGD and had a
relatively high number of units
in the dense layer.
This gives great ideas about
what we can experiment with
next. I can skew the scatter
plot view which shows the
correlation between the
different hyperparameters and
metrics.
I can, again, select a region
here to
view those points across the
other charts.
Just to summarize, we have
looked at TensorBoard in Colab.
An easier way to compare the
trend validation runs,
visualizing the keras conceptual
graph, and better hype parameter
tuning with the H-program
dashboard.
All this information is
available as documentation at
tensorflow.org/TensorBoard.
We also have a demo station
upstairs and would love to hear
from you.
Next up is Alex who will talk
about tf.function and autograph.
Thank you very much.
Hello. I am Alex. I am here to
tell you about how you are
going to build graphs in
TensorFlow 2.0. This might make
you a little uncomfortable
because we already spent time
early telling you in TensorFlow
2.0 we use eager execution by
default. So why am I taking that
away from you?
And I am not. Graphs are useful
for quite a few things.
The two ones I care the most
about
personally are that some
hardware like
our TPUs really benefit from the
full
program optimization if we have
graphs and if you have graphs
you can take your model and
deploy it on mobile and server
devices and make it available to
as many people as you can think
of.
At this point you are probably
-- I remember TensorFlow 1.0 and
the kind of code I had to write
to use graphs.
Where -- is he going to tell me
I have to keep doing that? No,
with TensorFlow 2.0 we are
changing the programming model
which builds the graphs in
TensorFlow.
We are removing that model where
you
add a bunch of nodes and rely on
session.run to prune things out
and figure out
the precise things you want to
run and
replacing it with a simpler
model based on the idea of the
function. We are calling it tf.
function because that is the
main API entry point. With tf.
function, many things you are
used to
are going to go away and I
dearly hope you won't miss them.
The first thing going away is
you will never have to use
session.run anymore.
[Applause]
If you have used TensorFlow
execution, you know how it work.
You have
tensors and operations.
Tf.function is just like an
operation
except one that you get to
define using a composition of
the other operations in
TensorFlow however you wish.
Once you have your tf.function,
you can call it inside another
function, you can take its
gradient, you can run it on the
GPU, on the TPU, on
the CPU, on distributed things
just like
you would do with any other
TensorFlow operation.
We are letting you define
oprations in Python and making
it as easy as possible and
trying to preserve as many of
the semantics of the Python
programming language you know
and love and when you execute
these functions in a graph.
So, obviously the first thing
you would think is that is it
actually faster?
If you look at models that are
large
conconvolutions it is not any
faster
because they execute plenty
fast. Res models get small and
you can measure the difference
in performance.
I show for this tiny LSTM cell
there is a 10-fold speed up if
you use tf.function verse if you
don't use tf.function to execute
it.
As I was saying, we really try
to preserve as much as the
Python semantics as we can to
make this code easy at a use.
If you have seen TensorFlow
graphs you
know they are not polymorphic
polymorphic.
Python code tends to be free in
the things it accepts. With tf.
function we do the same.
Under the hood, when you call a
tf.
function, we look at the
tensors you are passing and see
if you made a graph that is
compatible, if not we make a new
one. We hide them so you can use
your tf.function as you would
use a normal TensorFlow
operation and eventually you
will get all the graphs you need
built
up and your code will run BLAGZ
blazingly fast. If you want
accease the graphs you are
generating you can get them. We
expose them to you so you have
need
to manipulate the grap or do
weird things I don't approve you
can still do it. The main reason
we changed this model, really,
is not to replace session.run
with tf.function but it is by
changing the promise for what we
do to your code, we can do so
much more for you than we could
do before.
With the model where you add
nodes to a graph and prune them
it is hard for it TensorFlow
Runtime to know what order you
want the operations to be
executed in.
Almost every TensorFlow
operation is
stateless so it doesn't matter
but for where it does you
probably had to use control
dependencies other things to
make it work. I am here to tell
you you will never
have to use control dependencies
again if you are using
tf.function. The promise behind
tf.function is you write code
you would like to run eagerly,
we take it and make it run fast.
As we trace your Python code to
generate a graph, we look at the
operations you
run and every time we see a
stateful
operation, we add the minimal
necessary set of control
dependencies to ensure the
resources accessed are accessed
in the order you want them to
be. If you have two variables
you are updating we will do that
in parallel. If you have one
variable updating many times we
will order the updates so you
are not surprised by them
happening out of order or
something like that.
There is really no crazy
surprises and weird identifying
behavior.
You should never need to
explicitly add control
dependencies to your code but
you will still get the ability
of knowing what order things
execute.
If you want to check something
before something else, just put
that line of
code before that line of code
like how
you do normal programming.
We can simplify how you use
variables also. You know
variables are useful and let you
persist and checkpoint and all
those
things but they can be a little
finically.Thifinicy. Another
thing we are removing from
TensorFlow is the need to manual
initialize variables yourself.
The story for variables is a
little complicated because as we
try to make
code compatible with eager
execution and graph semantics
you will find examples where it
is unclear what we should do. My
favorite one is this one.
If you run this in TensorFlow 1.
X and session run repeatedly you
will get a series of numbers
that goes up.
But if you run the code eagerly,
every
time you run it you will get the
same number back. If I want to
wrap this code of tf.function,
which one should it do?
Follow the 1.X behavior or the
eager behavior?
I think if we took a poll I
don't agree with myself. This is
an area.
Non ambiguously created
variables is perfectly OK. You
can create a variable and
capture it by closure in a
function.
That is a way of a lot of
TensorFlow is written. You can
write the function so it only
creates variables the first time
it is called. This is what most
libraries in TensorFlow do under
the hood.
This is how keras is
implemented, sonnet, and all
sorts of other libraries that
use TensorFlow variables.
They try to take care to not
create variables every time they
are called otherwise you are
creating too many variables and
not training anything. Code that
behaves well gets thrown into
function and it is fine. If you
have seen this, I didn't need to
call the initializer for this
variable I am creating. It is
even better. I can make the
initializer depend on
the value of there argument of
the
FUNGSZFUNGSZ -- function in
arbitarily
ways and we add the dependencies
to make sure the state updates
happen in the way we want, so
there is no need to worry about
this.
You can create variables like
how you would use in a normal
programming
language and things behave the
way you want.
I am really happy about the
autograph integration as well.
If anyone has used TensorFlow
with
autograph it can be awkward but
we are
finally breaking up with the
prior forms
and you can write code that
looks like this.
I have a wild loop here and this
is
probably the worst way to make a
tensor. If you put this in a tf.
function it will put it in a
graph and execute it. This is
nice and great. How does it
work?
Under the hood things like tf.
file are still there but we have
tf.
autograph that rewrites control
expressions into something that
looks like this which is not how
you would want to write code.
This then can be taken by
TensorFlow and turned into fast
dynamic graph code.
How does this work? To explain
that I would like to take a step
back and think about how does
anything in TensorFlow work.
You can have a tensor and do
tensor
plus tensor times other tensors.
Just use a tensor like you would
a floating point number. Python
has a thing called operator
overloading that let's us change
the behavior of standard Python
operators
when applied on our custom data
types
like tensors.
We can add these underscores and
change
how TensorFlow does addition and
subtraction.
Python doesn't let us write
underscore underscore. It makes
me very sad.
If you this can  -- if you think
about this for a few second, you
can come up with rewrite rules
that will let us
lower to byte code with
underscore-underscore if that is
under writeable.
If code looks like this, you can
write this as condition.if a and
B.
You need to do fiddling of the
scopes because I am sure you
know Python's lexical scoping is
not as lexical as you think.
Names can leak out of scopes and
it is
a little messy but that is also
a mechanical transformation.
If this is potentially a
mechanical transformation let's
do this.
We wrote this compiler called
autograph that takes your Python
code and rewrites
it in a form that let's us call
underscore underscore if and etc
on tensors. This is all does but
this unlocks a lot
of the power of native Python
control into your tensor graphs.
On this function, I have two
loops.
One it is a static Python loop
because where write four I in
range. I is an integer.
Autograph sees this and leaves
it untouched.
You still get to use Python
control flow to chose how many
layers your
network will have or iterate
over a sequential but when your
control flow does depend on the
properties of tensors
like in the second loop for
intf.range then autograph sees
it and turns
it into a dynamic tf.wildloop.
This means you can implement
this in 10 lines of code just
like how you would
use in a normal language which
is pretty nice. And anything
that you can do in a TensorFlow
graph you can make happen
dynamically.
You can make prints and
assertions happen. Notice here
that I don't need to add control
dependencies to make sure they
happen in the right order
because of the thing we were
talking about earlier.
We already do. We control the
dependencies automatically for
you to try to really
make your code look and
behave the same as Python code.
The TensorFlow Runtime is not
powerful enough to support
everything that Python can do.
So, for example, if you are
manipulating list of tenors at
run-time you should still use a
tensor array.
It works very well and compiles
to eefficient TensorFlow code.
You no longer need to write the
boilerplate code associated with
it. This is how you stack a
bunch together in a loop.
Wrapping up, I think we have
changed a lot in TF 2.
I hope you agree the changes are
worth it. I will quickly walk
through you a dif of what your
code will look look before and
after.
Session run goes away.
Control dependencies go away.
Variable initialization goes
away.
Cond and
wildloop go away and you just
use functions like a normal
language.
Thank you and welcome to TF 2.
All the examples are on
tensorflow.
org/alpha and dig you will find
a Colab
notebook with these and more and
play
around with the tf.function for
auto.
Now I would like to introduce
Ryan who
is going to tell you about all
the ways we have of feeding data
into TensorFlow.
I am here to tell you about
TensorFlow datasets.
It is on GitHub and pipi. First
a little set-up.
This is the partnership care
about. TensorFlow 2.0 makes it
look nice.
You get predictions, your loss,
gradient, update, it all looks
fantastic. And they are good
together. Data and models.
Really, I just want to focus in
on this one piece. This one
line.
Iterating through your training
dataset.
In TF 2, with the training data
API,
you have this expressive simple
way of
expressing high performance but
flexible in put pipelines.
We might start with a TF dataset
and we
can shuffle and repeat and build
complex
pipelines and we know this will
be performance.
This map call might be doing
image preprocessing on each
record in the dataset. It is
happening in parallel you can
see here. TensorFlow will be
spinning up a bunch of threads
so the paping is high
performance. At the end, you
have the ability to pre-fetch.
As your tight model training
loop is
going, you can be preparing
batches ready to feed into the
iteration.
This is fantastic bit but
unfortunately
the source data is a little out
of step.
We want this tight iteration
with four iputs and targets.
What is hidden is how did you
get the data into a format that
you can feed into the model in
the first place?
Every source dataset when is all
a little bit different. This
makes sense when you distribute
data at rest there is some
natural format you would like to
distribute it in. We are not
interest in data at rest. We are
interested in having data in a
format that is ready to move
into a TF data pipeline.
What we really want is something
that is good together.
We want these two pups, data and
model,
to really be simpatico. It is
about getting data into a format
that is ready to move into a tf.
data pipeline. Here is
TensorFlow datasets.
You import TensorFlow datasets
and this
load API for
mnist, and we are grabbing the
training split of the dataset.
We are asking for supervised
tuples.
We will get input and target
tuples. We get a tf.
data dataset and we can build a
complex pipeline. We are adding
shuffling and batching in this
case.
We are off and we can iterate
through our inputs and do all
the modeling things we need.
Load hides a lot of the
complexity. What is happening
here with load is that mnist is
being fetched from the source,
it is being pre-processed, put
into a standard format, and it
is being documented with
statistics and everything which
I will show you in a second, and
then you are building the sort
of front end where you have
preprocessed data on disks ready
to move.
Typically you would only do this
one and tf.ds will tash the
results for you and you are
getting a tf.data pipeline out
of it.
We don't just for mnist. We have
imagenet.
The first step is running this
batch script, muck with the
files over here, make sure you
filter out these records and
things like that and of course
this
is all taken care of for you.
ImageNet is gated with a
password and
username and so currently
TensorFlow datasets ask you to
download the data and put it in
a certain place and TensorFlow
datasets takes it from there.
We are working with cagal to get
ImageNet to be downloaded
without any user interaction.
We are imdb reviews in this
case.
Note the API doesn't change.
This is a tfts data call.
Of course, text is a notoriously
difficult format to work with
when you are interested in doing
machine learning on it you have
to do encoding. We are shipping
with three really
powerful
encodings one is byte level,
character loading encoding and
another is subwords.
We have a great subword text
encoder.
We will get imdb reviews already
encoded using a vocabulary with
about 8,000 tokens.
Each of these datasets is
packaged together as a dataset
builder.
If you want to add a dataset to
TensorFlow datasets, which I
hope every single one of you do,
there should be
about a thousand new datasets in
a week, dataset builder is
simple.
It does those exact three things
lat load hiding. It has a method
called download and prepare
taking source data on the local
web or local directory and
produces preprocessed files. It
takes data at rest and put it
into a format of data ready to
move.
The second is as dataset and
that takes the preprocessed
files on disk and
produces a tf.data.dataset.
It third is metadata about the
dataset.
Dataset.info has the features in
the dataset and each feature
documents the name, shape and
type.
So in this case, the image for
mnist is
28, 28 by 1, type int 8. The
number of classes is documented
in the class label feature and
you get
statistics on the dataset and
what are the splits exposed,
train and set, and how many
records in each one.
Mnist has 60,000 in the training
and 10,000 for it testing. If
you want to grab a dataset from
TensorFlow datasets and filter
for all
the ones that are trivially
supervised datasets, you can
look for supervised keys and
pick up the features you need.
For text, again, one of these
things
that is a bit annoying to work
with
often, so this is imdB reviews.
The text feature contains the
encoder.
We see it is a texting encoder
with a vocabulary size of 8,
185.
We support numpy usage as well.
We want to make TensorFlow
datasets really portable.
You can call this tfts as
umpy arrays. Coming back to our
initial example, you know, we
have this beautiful, you know,
model and data, but of course
trained dataset -- where did
this come from and how did you
get the data? With TensorFlow
datasets a simple change and you
have something that works
end-to-end, out of the box,
which is something we are really
happy about and hope you are
too.
You can come find us on pypi and
GitHub.
The community on GitHub has
gotten surprisingly active
surprisingly quickly. Come join
us. We could use your data if
you are
distributing a dataset and would
like to
make your dataset famous, please
add it. Come help us on GitHub.
There are dataset requests and
you can
help implement a dataset that
has been requested or help us
develop. We develop out in the
open and develop straight out on
GitHub.
Thanks very much.
Hopefully you guys find this
useful and
come help us out. Thank you.
Next is something that I think
is really great.
Chris Lattner
and Brendon telling you about
Swift for TensorFlowTensorFlow.
Thanks, Brian. Fantastic. Hi, I
am Chris and this is Brennan and
we are super excited to tell you
about a new approach to machine
learning. Here in the TensorFlow
team, it is our jobs to push the
state-of-the-art of machine
learning forward. We have
learned a lot over the last few
years with deep learning. We
have incorporated most of that
all into TensorFlow 2.
0 and we are really excited
about it.
Here we are looking further
beyond than TensorFlow 2.0.
Eager mode makes it easy to
train dynamic model, but
deploying it still requires you
take that and write a bunch
of C++ code to help drive it.
That could be better. Some
researchers are interested in
taking machine learning models
and integrating them into larger
applications.
That often requires writing C++
code also.
We want more expressive and
differential
mechanisms and we are excited to
define reusable types that can
be put into new
places and used with automatic
differentiate. We want to make
your more productive by taking
errors in your code and
improving your iteration time.
Now, what we are really trying
to do here is lift TensorFlow to
entirely new heights. We need to
innovate at all levels of the
stack and this includes the
compiler and the language. That
is what's Swift for TensorFlow
is about all.
We think that applying new
solutions to old problems with
help push machine learning even
further than before. Let's jump
into some code. First, what is
Swift?
Swift is a modern and class
platform language designed to be
easy to learn and use. Swift
uses types which are great
because they can help you catch
errors earlier and encourage
good API design.
Swift uses type inference so it
is easy to use and elegant but
it is also open
source and has an open evolution
language processing allowing us
to change the language and make
it better.
This is how you define a model
in Swift for TensorFlow. We are
laying out our layers here and
we can define a forward function
which
com poses them together in a
linear sequence.
You probably noticed this looks
like keras and that is no error.
All we have to do to train is
substantiate the model, pick an
optimizer and random data and a
training loop. We will write it
by hand because that gives you
the maximum flexibility to play
with constructs and you can do
whatever you want.
Some of the major advantages of
Swift for TensorFlow is the
workflow.
Instead of telling you about it,
what do you think Brian?
--
Brennan.
What could be easier than
opening up a browser tab?
This is Google Colab hosted
Jupyter notebooks and comes with
Swift for TensorFlow built right
in.
Let's see it in action.
Here is the layer model or the
model that Chris just showed you
a couple slides ago.
We are going to run it using
some
random training data right here
in the browser. We will
instantiate the data and trained
it using Swift for TensorFlow in
our browser on training data
right here. We can see the
training losses decreasing over
time so that is great,
but if you are ever like me when
I try to use machine learning in
any application, I start with
the simple model and I have to
iterate. I have to tweak the
model to make it fit better to
the task at hand. So, since we
are trying to show you the
workflow, let's edit this model,
let's make it more accurate.
Here we are. Now, let's think a
little for a moment.
What changes do we want to make
to our model?
This is deep learning
after all so the answer is
always to go deeper.
Not just sequential layer but
skip connections are a good idea
to make sure your model
continues to train effectively.
Let's go through and actually
add an
extra layer to our model, let's
add skip
connections, and we will do it
all right now in under 90
seconds. Are you ready?
Here we go. We need to define
our additional layer first.
We will fill in this dense
layer.
One thing you can see is that we
are using tab auto complete to
help fill in code as we are
trying to develop and modify our
model.
Now, we are going to fix up the
shapes right here really quick
so that the residual connections
will all work. If I can type
properly that would go better.
Great.
We have now defined our model
with the additional layers. All
we need to do is modify the
forward
pass so that we add those skip
connections. Here we go. The
first thing we need to do is
store
in a temporary variable the
output of the flattened layer.
Then we will feed that output to
our first dense layer.
Dense.
applied to tmp in context.
For the cuda graphs here is our
dense applied.
Tmp plus tmp2 in context. Run
that.
Yes, it worksism -- works. Let's
see how it does.
We will reinstantiate our model
and run the training loop.
This loss is now substantially
lower.
This is an example of what it is
like to use Swift for TensorFlow
as you apply
and develop models for
applications and challenges.
[Applause]
Thank you.
But Swift for TensorFlow was
designed for researchers and
researchers often
need to do more than just change
models
and change the way architecture
fits together.
They need to define entirely new
abstractions and layers. Let's
see that live right now.
Let's define a new custom layer.
Let's say we had the brilliant
idea we wanted to modify the
standard dense layer that takes
weights and biases and
add an additional bias set of
parameters.
We will define this double bias
dense layer right here. I am
going to type this quickly.
Stand by. 15 seconds. Here we
go!
[Laughter]
That was great. Let's walk
through the code so you can see
what is going on. The first
thing that we have is we define
our parameters.
These are w, like our weights
for our
neurons and B1 and B2.
We define an initializer that
takes an input and output size
just like dense
does and we use that to
initialize our parameters. The
forward pass is very simple to
write.
Here is just aplied to and we
take the matrix multiplication
of input by our
weights and add in our bias
terms. We have just defined a
custom layer in Colab in just a
few lines of code. Here is model
two and we will use our
double bias dense layer and we
are going
to instantiate and use our
custom handwritten training
loop. Because TensorFlow can
statically analyze your code, it
can be really helpful to you. I
don't know about you but I
regularly
put typos in my code and Swift
for TensorFlow is helping you
out.
It is saying look, you mistyped
softcross-in.
This is not the right idea but
this is an example of how easy
it is for researchers to
experiment with new ideas
really easily in Swift for
TensorFlow but let's go deeper.
Swift for TensorFlow is, again,
designed for researchers and
researchers need to be able to
customize everything. That is
the whole point of research.
So, let's show an example of how
to customize something other
than just a model or layer.
You may have heard that large
GPU
clusters or TPU super pods are,
like, delivering massive
breakthroughs in
research and advancing the
state-of-the-art in certain
applications and domains.
You may have always heard as you
scale up you need to increase
your batch size.
Let's say you are a researcher
and you want to try and figure
out what are the
best ways to train deep neural
networks
at larger batch sizesment if you
are a researcher, you probably
can't guy a whole GPU cluster or
went a whole TPU
super pod all the time for your
experiments but you often have a
GPU under your desk.
Let's see how we can simulate
that on a single machine.
We will do it all in a few lines
of code here. Here is our custom
training loop and the standard
part. This is our 1-10 training
epics. What we will do is
instead of just
applying our model forward once,
we have an additional interloop,
right?
We will run our forward pass, we
will run our model four times,
and we are
going to take the gradients for
each
step and aggregate them in this
grads variable.
This simulates running on four
independent accelerates in a
data parallel fashion on a batch
that is four
times as large as what we
actually run.
We will then use our
optimizer.
That is all there is to it. We
are really excited by this
flexibility and capabilities
that Swift for TensorFlow brings
to researchers. Back over to
you, Chris.
Thanks, Brennan.
[Applause]
So I think the focus on catching
errors early and also
productivity enhancements like
code completion can help you in
a lot of ways. It's not just
about automating typing
of code, but it can be about
discovery of APIs. So another
thing that is really cool
about Swift as a language is it
has good interoperability with C
code.
You can import header files and
call directly from C without
wrappers or boilerplate or
anything involved. It just
works. We have taken this
approach in the TensorFlow and
brought it to the world of
Python. One of the cool things
about this is that allows you to
combine the power of Swift for
TensorFlow with all the
advantages of the Python Eco
system. How about we take a
look?
Thanks, Chris.
The Python data science
ecosystem is incredibly powerful
and vibrant.
We wanted to make sure you
didn't miss
your favorite libraries and
utilitiesio
you are  --
utilities you were used to.
Let's see how this works in
context to
numpy.
We import py plot from the
library and
numpy and assign it to np.
After that we can use np just as
if we were in Python.
We will call sine and cosine and
pass them to py plot.
When we run the cell, it just
works
exactly as you would expect.
[Applause]
Thank you. Now, this sort of
kind of looks like
the Python code you are used to
writing but this is actually
pure Swift. It just works
seamlessly. This is maybe a bit
of a toy example.
Let's see this a little bit more
more in context.
OpenAI has done a lot of work in
the area of reinforcement
learning and
developed a Python library
called OpenAI gym which contains
a collection of environments
that are very useful when you
are trying to train a
reinforcement agent across a
variety of different challenges.
Let's use OpenAI gym to train a
reinforcement agent in
TensorFlow right in our
browsers. The first thing we
need to do is import
gym and define a few
hyperparameters and now define
our neural networks.
We will pick a simple two layer
dense network in this case and
it is just a sequential model.
After that we have helper code
to filter
out bad or short episodes and
whatnot. Here is the real meat
of it.
We will use gym to instantiate
the cart pole environment and we
will instantiate our network in
the optimizer and here is our
training loop. We are going to
get a bunch of
episodes, we are going to run
our model, get the
gradientgradients and apply
those to the optimizer and
record the mean rewards as we
train. Very simple,
straightforward Swift.
And here you go see us training
a Swift
for TensorFlow in an OpenAI gym
environment using the Python
bridge. Totally seamless.
Afterwards, you can keep track
of the parameters of the
rewards. In this case we will
plot the mean
rewards as the model trained
using Python Numpy. Totally
seamless. You can get started
using Swift for TensorFlow using
all the libraries you know and
love and take advantage of what
Swift for TensorFlow brings to
the table.
Back over to you, Chris.
Thanks, Brennan.
One thing I love about this is
it is not just about leveraging
big important libraries.
We are working on the ability to
integrate Swift for TensorFlow
and Swift for Python together
which we think will provide a
nice path to help you
incrementally move code from one
worth to the other.
I think it is fair to say
calculus is
an intergral part of machine
learning. We think
differentiable programming is so
important we built it right into
the
language enabling more flexible
and custom work with
derivatives. We think this is
really cool. I would like to
take a look.
We have been using Swift for
TensorFlow's differential
programming
throughout the demo but let's
really break dedown.
Here we define my function that
takes two doubles and returns a
double based
on some products and sums and
quotients. If we want Swift for
TensorFlow to automatically
compute the derivative for
us, I would annotate it at
differential.
Swift for TensorFlow will then
derive the derivative for this
function right when we run the
cell.
To use this auto generated
derivative, use gradient which
takes a closure to evaluate and
a point you want to evaluate
your closure at. Here we go.
This is what it is to take the
derivative of a function at a
particular point. We can change
this around. This one is my
favorite. Tasty number. That
works nicely.
One thing to note is we have
been taking the partial
derivatives of my function with
respect to A. Of course you can
take the partial
derivative and get a full
gradient of my function like so.
Often with neural networks,
however, you
want to get not just the
gragradients, you often want
what the network predicted?
This is useful to compute
accuracy or other debugging sort
of information.
For that, you can use value with
gradient.
That returns a tuple containing
the value and gradient
shockingly enough.
One thing to note, in Swift
tuples can have named
parameters. You can see it
prints out nicely and you can
access values. We think this is
another nice little thing that
helps make writing and debugging
code and more importantly
reading it and understanding it
later a little bit easier. The
one thing I want to call out is
throughout this we have been
using normal types.
These are not tensor of
something. It is just plain old
double.
This is because automatic
differentiateation is built
right in and
it makes it easy to express your
thoughts very clearly. But even
though it is built into the
language, we have worked very
hard to
make sure automatic differiation
is customizeable. Let's show
you.
Let's say you want to define an
algebra in 2d space.
You are certainly going to need
a point data type.
Here we define a point instruct
with X
and Y and mark it
differentiable. We can define
helper functions on it like dot
or other helper functions. Swift
for TensorFlow when you try and
use your code it will often
automatically infer when you
need
gradients to be automatically
computed for you by the
compiler. It is a good idea to
document your intentions so you
can annotate your helping
functions as at differentiable.
The  other reason we recommend
doing this is because it helps
catch errors.
Swift for TensorFlow is telling
you that hey, you can only
differentiate functions that
return values that
conform to differentiable but
int doesn't conform to
differentiable.
This is telling you my helper
function
returns an int and int is about
taking small steps and integers
are very discreet.
Swift for TensorFlow is helping
to catch errors right when you
write the code and tell you what
is going on.
The solution, of course, is to
just not
mark it as a differentiable and
the cell runs just fine. Let's
say we also wanted to go beyond
just defining the dot product.
Let's say we wanted to define
the magnitude helper function.
That is the magnitude of the
vector
defined by the origin to the
point in question.
To do that, we can use the
distance formula and we can
define the extension
on point that does this.
We will pretend for a moment
that Swift doesn't include a
square root function because I
want a good excuse for you to
see the interopera
interoperability with C.
We will use C's square root
function. We can define the
magnitude and it -- no, it
doesn't quite work.
Let's see what is going on. We
wanted magnitude to be
differentiable and it is saying
you can't differentiate the
square root
function because this is an
external function that hasn't
been marked as differentiable.
The square root is a C function
compiled by the C compiler and
that
can't automatically compute
derivatives for you. This is
saying it will not work and
this is excellent because it
gives me a great excuse to show
you how to write custom
gradientss.
We define a wrapper function
here that calls to the C square
root function. The backwards
pass, we take our double,
and we return to a tuple of two
values. Rather the first element
in the tuple is the normal value
and the forward pass.
The second a pullback closure
and this is where you define the
backwards pass capturing
whatever values you need from
the forward pass.
We are going to run that.
We are going to go back up to
the
definition of magnitude and
change it
from square root to my square
root, rerun the cell and it
works.
We defined point, dot and
magnitude. Here I defined the
silly function and marked it as
differentiable. We are going to
take two points, we are also
going to take a double, right?
You can mix and match
differentiable
data types totally fluidly.
We will do magnitude and dot
products. It is a silly
function.
We can use it, compute the
gradient of
this function at arbitrary data
points. You can get the value of
there function
and full gradients in partial
derivatives with respect to
individual values.
That has been a quick run
through of
custom gradients J custom data
types
with the differentiate built in.
Let's put all this together and
show how you can write your own
debuggers as
an example of how this power is
all in your hands.
Often when you are developing
models, you want to -- or
debugging models, you want to be
to see the gradients at
different points within your
model.
We can define in regular Swift
code a gradient debugger.
It will take as input, a double,
and it is going to return it
just like normal for the forward
pass, right?
It is an identity function. We
will get the gradient, print it
and return it. We are just
passing it through printing it
out. We have defined this
gradient debugger and we can use
it in our silly function
to see what is going on as we
take derivatives.
Gradientdebugger, here we go. We
can rerun that.
And when we take the gradients,
we can see that for that point
in the silly function, of a.
b, the gradient is 3.80.
That's been a brief through of
how
automatic differiation works and
how you
can extract the power to build
whatever systems you need. Back
over to you, Chris.
The algorithms we are defining
were built in the 1970s.
There is a tremendous amount of
depth
and I am excited to see what you
all can do it about.
If you are interested in
learning more, we are detail
documents online.
The language of Swift has low
level performperformance and
there is no gill to get in the
way of concurrency.
They have advanced compiler
techniques to identify and
extract graphs for you. The
consequence of this together is
we
think Swift has the world's most
advanced eager mode. You may
wonder why do we care about this
stuff?
We are seeing trends in the
industry
where people are defining neural
networks. This requires you to
export graphs and write a bunch
of C++ code to load and
orchestrate them in various
ways.
Let's look at an example of
this.
Alpha go-
zero is amazing work.
You have deep learning and it
drives through it Monte Carlo.
It is the combination of all
three
things that make AlphaGo Zero
possible.
This is possible today.
If you are an advanced team like
DeepMind you can do this. We
think breaking down barriers
like this can lead to new
breakthroughs in science and
drive progress forward. Instead
of talking about it, again,
let's take a look.
MiniGo is an Open Source Go
player
inspired by DeepMind's AlphaGo
Zero.
The miniGo project were writing
everything in normal TensorFlow
and it was working great until
tay started trying to run at
scale on large clusters of TPUs.
They ran into performance
problems and
had to rewrite things into C++
to effectively utilize the
modern accelerators.
We have reimplemented Monte
Carlo
research and the rest of MiniGo
player in Swift. We define a
helper function, these are
our white and black players, we
are going to run basically play
the game until we have a winner
or looser. So, let's actually
run this.
We define a game configuration
and we
will play between a Monte Carlo
tree search versus a random
player to see how
easy it is to flip back and
forth or mix and match between
deep learning and other
arbitrary machine learning
algorithms right here in Swift.
Here you go.
You can see them playing white,
black, playing different moves
back and forth and it just goes.
We think that Swift for
TensorFlow is going to unlock
whole new classes of algorithms
and research because of how
easy it is to do everything in
one language with no barriers
and not rewriting everything
into the C++. Back to you,
Brennan.
The cool thing about this is you
can do
something like this in a work
workbook. We have seen families
of techniques that can be bound
together and fused and bringing
this to more people we think
will lead to new kinds of
research. Our work on usability
and design is not just about
high-end researchers.
We love them but Swift is widely
used
to teach new programmers to
learn how to code.
I am excited to announce a new
journey
we are embarking on with Jeremy
Howard.
At fast.ai we are always looking
to push the boundaries of what
is possible especially pushing
to make recent
advances more accessibility. We
have been involved with this and
building the world's best
document classifier.
Hundreds of thousands have
become deep
lun  learners.
We
think with Swift for TensorFlow
we can go even further.
We are announcing a new program
caught by someone that knows
Swift well.
Chris, I think he means you.
I am super excited to help teach
the
next generation of learners and
excited
Jeremy is bringing his expertise
in
Swift and helping us shift the
higher level APIs. The most
important part is Swift for
TensorFlow is really TensorFlow
at its core and we think this is
super important.
We have worked hard to make sure
it integrates with all things
going on in the big TensorFlow
family and we are very excited
about that.
You may be wondering where you
can get this. Swift for
TensorFlow is Open Source. You
can find it on GitHub now and
you can join our community.
It also works great in Colab as
you have seen today. We have
tutorials and examples and the
demos you saw today are
available in Colab.
We have released our 0.2 release
including all the basic
infrastructure and underlying
technology to power these demos
and examples and we are actively
working on high-level APIs right
now.
This is not ready for production
yet as you can guess but we are
excited about
shaping the future, building
this out, exploring this new
program model, and
this is a great example for
advanced researchers to get
involved and help shape the
platform. We would love for you
to try it out and let us know
what you think.
Next up, I would like to invite
Edd to
talk about the TensorFlow
community.
Thanks, Chris.
Hey, everybody. I work with
TensorFlow helping build
community and collaboration
around the open source project.
Usually I put the thank you
slide at the end for listening
to me but actually I want to
thank you for contributing and
being part of the TensorFlow
project. Whether you are here in
this room or on the livestream,
there has been some amazing talk
on YouTube from people in China,
and India, and Japan, and all
over the world joining us
virtually today. Thank you for
your contributions.
The project is where it is today
because of you.
Of course, in core TensorFlow
alone we have had this many
commits.
This figures out over 50,000
from over 18,000 contributors
and much more than just code
commits.
39,000 stackoverflow questions
about TensorFlow, we have 66
machine learning
Google developer experts, many
of whom who are here with us
today.
Welcome and thank you guys. It
is really great to have you with
us and thank you for everything
you do helping teach people
about TensorFlow. We have had 14
guest posts to the
TensorFlow blog and that keeps
going up.
There are so many ways people
are contributing. Thank you.
You are really helping build out
the TensorFlow ecosystem. I want
to discuss how we are growing
the Eco system and report back
on some of the changes we have
made over the last year. I am
going to cover how we are making
it easier to get involved in
TensorFlow and how we are trying
to consult betwer
the users in the community and
be more transparent about our
development. Going to cover how
we are empowering everybody to
get involved and to do more
and increasing in the number of
contact points.
I will go a bit more into depth
about the conference announced
today.
Let's talk about how we are
making
contributions to TensorFlow
easier.
One of there most important
thing is
increasing its modularity.
We are trying to make it less of
a mono lift.
When you come and want to
contribute to an open source
project it helps to know where
to go.
We are creating more surface
area. Our special interest
groups play a big
part in this and I will talk a
bit more about them later. It is
not just code.
There is so many more places to
contribute this year compared to
last year. I will talk about the
documentation groups, groups
involved in testing, groups who
are blogging and on YouTube and
more.
I was super excited to see we
published
TensorFlow tutorial in Korean.
That isn't something we did on
our team. That is part of the
community.
We were similarly able to
publish it in
Russian thank you to Andrew
Stepin.
I am also really excited about
the TensorFlow 2.0 testing group
led my Paige Bailey. This is a
bunch of contributors and
Google developer experts who are
working to get TensorFlow 2.0 a
test. You see an example of
friction load and
folks are going through ML loads
and documenting what they find
awesome and also things that
could be a little better.
This group meets weekly and
often has
guest talks from maintainers and
SIGs leaders and it helping
bring TensorFlow 2.0 from
cutting edge to something
thoroughly tested and ready to
use.
We mentioned we have over 14
posts from guests on the
TensorFlow blog.
This is from a great post about
real-time segmentation with
TensorFlow.js that comes from a
grad student and researcher at
itp. Whether it is testing,
whether it is documentation,
whether it is blogs or
conference talks, thank you.
Now, I want to talk a little bit
about TensorFlow RFCs.
As you probably know, RFC means
request for comments. This time
last year, we were not that
organized about how we evolved
TensorFlow's design in terms of
communicating and I stood on
this stage and told you about
launching the RFC process.
We have accepted 21 of them over
the period of the last year.
This is our way to communicate
design. We post an RFC about a
design and consult widely.
This isn't just about code
coming outwards, it can be
created on and commented on by
anyone.
We have several RFCs brought by
the broader community and I
expect to see several more. One
of the things I am most proud
about
is how the RFC process is
underpinning the 2.0 transition.
All the major changes have been
proposed and consulted with in
RFCs. This isn't just a great
way of consulting and getting
feedback, going
forward you have a big
repository of documentation
about why design choices were
made a certain way in TensorFlow
and great educational results
for people who are coming on and
want to get involved in
contributing to the project. I
really want to give a big thanks
to
anyone who authored or reviewed
an RFC.
You played a vital role in
making TensorFlow better. Let's
talk a bit about the social
structure of TensorFlow. You
know, last year I talked about
how coming to a large project
can be a little bit daunting.
You don't know where people are,
whether people have your
interest in common. We created
the special interest groups or
SIGs as a way of organizing our
work. There are so many uses of
TensorFlow, so many environments
and architectures.
Many of them are outside of the
scope
of the core team and we want to
enable TensorFlow to grow and be
more
sustainable by creating a way
for like-minded people to
collaborate.
This is why SIGs exist. They are
groups of people working
together for a define project
focus.
We started last year and we have
six up and running now.
I am going to give you a quick
state of
the SIGs and many, in fact most
of the leaders, are here with
us. I will give a shout out to
them and hopefully you will be
able to talk to
them in the launch and tomorrow.
SIG addons first.
Martin mentioned at the
beginning of the
day that TF contrib is no longer
a part
and SIG addons are where that is
going.
They conform to these well
defined APIs.
Most  there is already an RFC
posted
about where you can find things
that you
used to find in contrib. How can
you get involved if you have a
favorite and want to step up and
be a maintainer for everybody
and how you can join in the
project.
I encourage you to take a look
at that. SIG build is where
TensorFlow meets the outside
world. It is not always the most
glamorous
piece of work but building it
and
packaging and distributing it is
tough.
Thank you to
Jason and Austin who lead that
SIG.
It is home for third party
builds for architectures we
don't ship.
IBM power and SIG helps us be a
better neighbor in the Python
ecosystem.
Machine learning generates a lot
of extreme situations and
changes in the
way we package and distribute
software.
SIG-IO helps connect other
systems and your data NLT real
world exists using systems in
other formats.
This group is led my yang tan
and antoine. If you are using
any of these in the
Apache Eco system or the
environments
you can use this addaddon. This
group has already dropped four
releases and shipped our
integration
with their module too.
SIG networking is where a lot
are going to.
If you are using gdr verbs this
is where you can find this.
If you are interested in this,
or any
of the other SIGs, please talk
to the leaders. They want help
and are up and running
and in a great place to bring
people on.
If you are looking for a way to
get involved in TensorFlow, this
is an ideal one.
Let me talk about SIG
TensorBoard.
This is a great time to be
involved as
the TensorBoard team is trying
to figure out how we can best
enable people using TensorBoard
for creating plugins or at
scale. If you go to the demo
area above and go
to the TensorBoard stand you
will find
Gal and Moni there who would be
happy to talk to you. This is
the URL for anything you want to
do joining the TensorFlow
community from docs to testing
to SIGs and all the other ways
to be involved. The developer
mailing list. Please head there.
If you are here with us, rather
than on the livestream, we are
doing a
contributor
luncheon tomorrow where many of
the core
team and SIGs will be there to
talk to you. Finally, let's move
on and talk about TensorFlow
World. I am so excited about
this. It is our vision to bring
together the amazing people who
are part of our community and
give space for everyone to
connect with each other. There
is so much we can learn from how
we are all working with
TensorFlow. Working with
O'Rielly media, we will have
this event at the end of October
here in Santa Clara.
It will be four days that really
celebrate the TensorFlow
ecosystem.
We will have content, talks,
tutorials, there will be an expo
and place for vendors to
present. We understand
TensorFlow gets out into the
real world there is a large
ecosystem beyond folks in this
room. We are really excited and
that means we can bring everyone
together. The main point of
doing something like this is to
connect all the amazing users
and everyone with experience to
share. As you heard the call for
proposals is now open.
If you have anything to share
with your work, your product,
your company, head to TensorFlow
World and put in a proposal. You
have about 4-5 weeks while the
call for proposals is open and
we will be selecting talks a few
weeks after that.
I really hope you will
lend your voice to this event
and I am so excited to see you
in October. Once again, thank
you. We appreciate how much you
are part of our community.
In my job, the best thing every
day is
when I get to talk to folks
developing or using TensorFlow.
It is so exciting to work with
everybody here.
This is the way you can meet me.
Please do.
If you have any issue or devire
to contribute, reach out. We are
really happy to talk to you.
Thank you very much for your
attention. -- desire.
[Applause]
Hey, everybody. Thank you, Edd.
That was wonderful. We are at
another break. Come back here at
2:25. We will be talking about
TensorFlow in production. Then
the next block of talks is about
probability and so forth. Don't
forget to go upstairs.
We have deem demos of all kinds
of stuff and Googlers galore.
Check it out. Thanks a lot.
.
>>PAIGE BAILEY: Eager execution
and all
of the things that we have loved
to come to know and love through
the last several iterations of
TensorFlow development.
We have a lot of tutorials and
documentation that have been
recently released, it is about
making you
productive as quick
as possible, and giving you
scalable,
reproducible learn
ing.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: Yes, and
with it being open source, of
course, is the
community is just a huge part of
what we do.
>>PAIGE BAILEY: We could not do
it without the community.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: And that is
why we are doing the live
stream.
>>PAIGE BAILEY: If you have
questions, #askTensorFlow is the
hashtag.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: And one
question
that we are going to cover, you
will get
today, it is great to do my
training for
a fixed number of epochs, but
when I reached the desired
accuracy metric, how do I
continue training?
>>PAIGE BAILEY: It is not easy
to compute if you have gotten to
a point where your boss says,
okay, cool, 99 percent accuracy,
that is fine for us today.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: Should we
take a look at how we are doing
that?
>>PAIGE BAILEY: Absolutely.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: I opened up
a codelab where you can see
where I'm
causing call backs, and call
backs are the ways that you
would achieve this.  And at the
top, you can see the class, the
call back.
And then when an epoch ends in
training, I can look at the
logs.
If the accuracy log is greater
than 60
percent, he is really happy that
I'm on the training, 60 percent
accuracy, then I would cancel
the training.
And then to be able to set it
up, I
would create an object, call
backs, an
instance of the class, and I
love the
click-in, the little things that
I love, and call backs equal
call backs, and
when I do the training, I will
show off
and make my run time tied to the
GPU, so it is really fast. So
let's do a little bit of
training with this one, so I'm
doing this live
and I'm connecting to the VM, it
is training, getting ready to --
>>PAIGE BAILEY: The RAM and disk
utilization.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: We are on
the first epoch, that is
progressing away, 60,000
images being trained
, and I hit accuracy of 83,
which is really good.  But it
reached 60 percent accuracy, so
I canceled the training.
Call backs are helpful, before I
learned about call backs, it is
like, I
would set something up to train
for 100 epochs, go to sleep,
wait up the next morning, and
after three epochs, it didn't do
its job and I wasted the time.
>>PAIGE BAILEY: Yes, call backs
are incredibly invaluable, it
does not just apply to accuracy
either.  There's a bunch of
additional metrics that can be
useful for your particular
workflow, and this code works in
TensorFlow 2.0.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: Absolutely.
>>PAIGE BAILEY: So it is Caras,
I love Caras.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: It is a love
affair, and one neat thing about
Caras that you
might not realize, is the same
code for TensorFlow 1.x is the
same for 2.0, so what is going
on behind the scenes is it is
equally in 2.0 instead of a
graph mode.  So this codelab, 1.
13, this code will run in 2.0
without you modifying the code.
>>PAIGE BAILEY: Absolutely.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: Should we
take the next question?
>>PAIGE BAILEY: Cool. So the
next question is from Twitter it
looks like.  And what about all
the web developers who are new
to AI ?
Does the version 2.0 help them
get started?
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh web
developers.
>>PAIGE BAILEY: I just finished
talking to two folks from the
TensorFlow JS team about the
cool new things they have seen
from the community, a vibrant
ecosystem of artists and
creators that are using
browser-based and server-based
tools to create these machine
learning models, training and
running them.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: Yep. And
for web developers, there's a
whole bunch of ways you can get
started with this.  So you
mentioned TensorFlow JS, we will
start with that, but it is a
JavaScript library.
And this will allow you to train
models in the browser, as well
as executing them.  And that
blew my mind.
>>PAIGE BAILEY: And the node
bindings, being able to use the
GPU inside your
laptop with, you know, Google
Chrome or your favorite flavor
of browser, to
train a model
.  That is absurd.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: And node
bindings as well, with node.JS.
It is not only in JavaScript,
but server-side JavaScript with
node.  And am I supposed to say
Node.js? I will say node.  And,
of course, by the fact that it
is a node, one of my personal
favorites, are you familiar with
Cloud Functions for Firebase?
>>PAIGE BAILEY: I'm not, I'm
intrigued.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: I used to
work on the Firebase team, so
shout out to my friends on
Firebase.
>>PAIGE BAILEY: I have heard so
many good things about Firebase.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: It is for
mobile and web developers, and
one of the things
that Firebase gives you are
these things
called Cloud Functions for
Firebase, I called up the web
page, and you can execute the
functions on the back end
without maintaining a server
infrastructure and execute them
in response to a trigger, such
as an
analytic event, or a sign-in
event.
>>PAIGE BAILEY: Or you get new
data and
you have to process it.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: There you
go. And the fact that they run
JavaScript code on the back end,
and now you can train models in
a cloud function.
>>PAIGE BAILEY: That's amazing.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: So web
developers, a lot of great
options for you.
However it is you want to do it,
in
the browser, the back end, you
can get started with it.
>>PAIGE BAILEY: And TensorFlow
2.0, if it gives additional
tools for application
developers, I think it would
mostly be in terms of those
codes and tutorial that we are
mentioning before.  And we also
released some courses.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: Yep.
>>PAIGE BAILEY: So it is easier
than ever to get started.
And, um, the models that you
create can
be deployed to TS lite.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: And we have
been talking about Caras, and
the layers are supported in
TensorFlow.JS.  It is not just
for Python developers, if you
are a JS developer, you can
define your layers.
>>PAIGE BAILEY: And an R
developer, they
have Caras for R, which was
created by
JJ Layer and Francois Chalet.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: A lot of
options for developers.  And
next question, from Twitter, are
there any JS learning examples
from object detection?
>>PAIGE BAILEY: Node.JS is
popular, we have learned.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: So object
detection.
How do we answer this? So I'm --
it depends on what you mean
by object detection because, in
Google, we talk about object
detection and use that term for,
in an image, you have a
lot of objects and bounding
boxes for them, there are
samples for that.
>>PAIGE BAILEY: And a lovely
thing is
the community is adept at
creating TensorFlow.
JS examples, for example, code
pens, and
Victor Dibia, a
machine learning expert, for
tracking hand movements.  So if
you want to create --
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: You have an
incentive.
>>PAIGE BAILEY: I have a limited
edition collection of TensorFlow
socks, and I would love to send
you a bright,
shiny pair of limited edition
socks.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: They are
classics, they have the old
logo.
>>PAIGE BAILEY: Not the new
logo, but the old box style
ones.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: I love them
both.
And, like the question was about
transfer learning, and we did
not have a demo of object
detection, I would love to show
Transfer Learning and being able
to detect a single item in the
frame.  To do that, we call
image classification.  So can I
roll the demo?
>>PAIGE BAILEY: Please do. Are
you going to do your favorite --
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: I am a child
of the '80s, I love Pac-Man.  So
you will notice that it says
loading mobile net now, so it
downloaded
the mobile net model.  So I'm
going to add some new classes to
the mobile net model and then
use transfer --
>>PAIGE BAILEY: There it goes.
No, no, go for it.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: So Pac-Man,
old arcade game, you try to move
away from the ghosts.
I will train it to move up when
I'm pointing up, I will gather
samples, about 50, when I go
right like this, and turning
left is going to be hard.  I
didn't think it through.  Bear
with me, so maybe I will do left
like this, get my head out of
the way, a few samples like
that, and then down will look
like this, and hopefully these
aren't weird gestures in some
country.  And something like
that, okay.
So I have now picked 50 samples
of these, I will retrain these
in the browser with transfer
learning.
So if I look at the rate, I will
start training and I will see --
it starts going quickly, you can
see the loss
started at 4, it went town down
down down, all to zero, and
probably a digit beyond the 6
digits,
never at zero, it is a very low
loss, now we will give it a try.
I will stop playing the game,
move left, you can see the
bounding box
around it, kind of shows that
I'm
up, right, watching the screen.
And now you can see that I have
trained it, going right this
time.  Right, right, and up.
And it thinks it is down, up,
and right.
And I'm not good at the game.
>>PAIGE BAILEY: You are using it
as an excuse to play Pac-Man all
day.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: It is a
great example of transfer
learning, and you can see in
JavaScript how easy it is to
extract the features from mobile
net and then retrain it, and it
is moving as I'm talking.
And so enough fun with Pac-Man
--
>>PAIGE BAILEY: Transfer
learning can be used for a
variety of cases.  So be sure to
look at the examples listed on
the website.
And this is on Twitter, which is
very popular.  Hi, dear ask
TensorFlow.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: We have to
respond to that, they said dear.
>>PAIGE BAILEY: Yes, are you
going to publish the updated
version of
TensorFlow, the poet's tutorial
from Pete Warden on TS2.
0, TS lite, and a lot of other
shenanigans.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: And the
network API.
>>PAIGE BAILEY: I love Pete
Warden's codelab on TensorFlow
for poets, and he had a great
talk today.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: I didn't get
to see it, I was preparing.
>>PAIGE BAILEY: It is about
creating
tiny models and putting them on
computers on mobile and embedded
devices.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: So at some
point, we will update it.  I
don't think there is an updated
version available, but one of
the things that I liked about
the TensorFlow for
poets codelab is it got me
building a model quickly for the
mobile device.  And the draw
back of that is there are
a bunch of scripts that I ran, I
didn't
know what I was going on with
them.
And I decided a bunch of
TensorFlow
lite examples, image
classification, object
detection, image recognition,
and speech detection.
They are all open source,
Android and
iOS, and they have full
instructions on how to do it
yourself.  The image
classification is fun, and I
will try and run that in my, um,
Android
Emulator, so we can see it
running in an emulated
environment.  So let me get that
started.  You can see it being
cached.
For example, here, it is doing a
classification of what is in the
background, if I hold up a water
bottle, this way, it detects it
is a water bottle.  This is
running in the Android Emulator,
okay? And this is using
TensorFlow lite, and this is the
sample on there that does the
same thing that you would seen
in TensorFlow for poets, it is
using mobile net and building an
application around mobile net.
If you look, running in the
emulator,
I'm getting inference times in
the 100 and 170 milliseconds.
>>PAIGE BAILEY: The ability to
take large scale models and sort
of pull them done to a
manageable side on a mobile, or
an embedded device, is huge, and
I'm excited to see what
TensorFlow lite does this year.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: So we are
working on a bunch of tutorials,
both samples are out there, if
you look at the GitHub page, you
will see that there are --
there are details on how it is
built.  Let me go back on here.
And there are details how it is
built, how you can put it all
together and compile it.
You don't need to use
build TensorFlow to use
TensorFlow lite, so you can go
and start kicking the tires on
these applications for yourself.
>>PAIGE BAILEY: Excellent.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: All right.
We will have more codelabs, I
would
love to get Pete's TensorFlow
for poets
updated, hopefully for I/O.
>>PAIGE BAILEY: And watch Pete's
talk.  It was so good, people
were talking
about putting models on
comadors.  I was nerding out a
little bit.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: And that's
why we're here.  Cool!
So -- do we have time for one
more question before break? So
we are heading to break now, so
Paige and I will be back after
the break with the rest of your
questions.  Please keep asking
them on the live stream and on
social media.  Like I said,
anything that we cannot get to,
we will try to get to offline
and we will reach out back to
you.
>>PAIGE BAILEY: Absolutely. So
super excited to have you here,
super excited to be at the
TensorFlow Developer Summit.
>>LAURENCE MORONEY: And we will
see you back here in a few
minutes.
>>PAIGE BAILEY: Yep.
[Music].
PAIGE BAILEY: Welcome back.  I'm
Paige Bailey.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: I'm Laurence
Moroney.
PAIGE BAILEY: We're here to
answer your TensorFlow questions
with #askTensorFlow.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: And we will
try to get back to you today, if
not, we will reach out to you
later to answer them.
PAIGE BAILEY: We will go to the
first question.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: This is on
Twitter,
once I installed TensorFlow GPU,
it did not work at first, failed
to run native TensorFlow run
time.
I remember seeing this one, it
was on YouTube in response to a
pip install
TensorFlow GPU in codelab,
because once
upon a time, you had to pip
install TensorFlow GPU to use
it, and now you are running into
issues, and the reason is good,
it is good news, you don't have
to run it anymore.
So if we switched to colab, this
is a notebook that I was showing
you earlier on.
If you wanted to use GPU in
colab, pick the run time type,
pick GPU as the hardware
accelerator and now you don't
need to pip install TensorFlow
GPU, it
does it under the hood behind
the scenes, it is really cool
and earlier
why I trained this so quickly, I
used the GPU and there is no pip
install GPU on here.
PAIGE BAILEY: When we were
installing TensorFlow 2.0, we
had an issue with the GPU
install,
and you needed specific
Kuta drivers.
Kolob is a great tip if you --
LAWRENCE MORONEY:
>>AND: GPU stuff, this is what
I ran into a number of times
when using the GPU, you have to
carefully take a look at the
version of Kuda and see the DNN
that you are using, because I
made the mistake that I just
went to the vendor's website, I
downloaded the latest version, I
installed them, and then I saw
TensorFlow was actually
supporting a slightly earlier
version.
So if you do get an error when
you are using GPU, take a look
at the version of the driver it
is looking to support and
then from the VEPD er vendor's
website, download that version.
PAIGE BAILEY: Driver issues,
they are always a treat.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: Exactly.  And
it is like -- it is one of the
things that makes our job
interesting.
PAIGE BAILEY: Absolutely.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: Haha, all
right.  Should we look at the
next one?
PAIGE BAILEY: Oh, let's go.
Adi Kumar had at least eight
excellent questions on Twitter.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: He wins the
volume award.
PAIGE BAILEY: He absolutely
does, we
will get to all of them, not in
this Ask TensorFlow segment, but
we will focus on one for today
and then answer the rest
offline.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: And I think a
lot of them were about file
formats and how do I use
different file formats.  Should
I drill into that?
PAIGE BAILEY: Absolutely.
The question is, which is the
preferred format for saving the
model going forward, saved
model, or something else?
If we look at the laptop, we can
take a gander at one of the
slides from the
keynote this
morning, that Keras is a driver
of 2.0 and this is at the heart
of the deployment.
You can see it for TensorFlow
serving, lite, and JS, and a lot
of other language bindings.
We are pushing for the saved
model.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: And you cannot
go wrong.
PAIGE BAILEY: It is easier to
use than the other deployment
options we have seen before.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: So I think the
guidance is in the
recommendation, not just for AD,
but for everybody else.  When
you are thinking about saving
your models, take a look at save
model, consider using it, and
not only is the
advantage of the file format,
but just how it is supported
across all of these.
PAIGE BAILEY: And an excellent
point of TensorFlow 2.
0, I will keep selling it, we
have a
number of code samples and
tutorials today on saved model.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: I was playing
with the
lite stuff, saving as a saved
model, and the TensorFlow lite
process was a lot easier for me.
So it is really refined, we are
iterating on that, and I think
it looks really cool.
PAIGE BAILEY: Yep!  Excellent.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: So thank you
for all
of those questions, Adi, we will
try to answer the rest of them,
most of them were focused around
the file format and hopefully
saved model will help you.
PAIGE BAILEY: Let's go to the
next one.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: This is from
Eli
Gaguba, is it possible to run
TensorBoard on codelabs?
PAIGE BAILEY: You are going to
be so delighted.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: Because before
if was running on codelabs, we
were talking about, we really
want to run codelabs.
PAIGE BAILEY: It is so painful!
If you wanted to get it working
in a
collab notebook, it was not
really approved by our bosses or
in general.  But, yes, so the
good news is that you
can run TensorBoard in codelab.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: And before it
was publicly announced, when it
was announced
internally, we got an email from
Paige with a lot of smily faces.
So thank you for your question,
it made Paige's day.
PAIGE BAILEY: And I'm
downloading files in hopes to
play with it a little bit, but
here you can see it working.
You should be able to do
different
operations like smoothing
, and changing the values and
using the
embedding visualizer from the
Collab
notebook to improve your
accuracy and model debugging.
Another thing that we are
working
very, very hard on is you don't
have to specify ports.  You
don't need to remember if you
have multiple TensorBoard
instances running,
that you are using 6006, or
whatever, for another.
It automatically selects one
that's a good candidate, and it
would create a good fit for you.
So the team is phenomenal, if
you have
any interest whatsoever in
TensorBoard at all, I recommend
stalking the POs, like I do.
That's how I found out that
TensorBoard was added to Jupiter
notebooks and also to codelab.
So it is so exciting, we will
have this link in the
documentation as well, the
little notes underneath for you
to play it.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: It is so great
to have a PR stalker [ laughter
].
PAIGE BAILEY: I get push
notifications in my phone, it is
a problem.  But they are doing
such great work.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: So yes,
TensorBoard is working in
Collab.
PAIGE BAILEY: And also project
Jupyter notebooks!  TensorBoard
everywhere.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: And we all
love it.  I have not played with
it that much, do the plugins
work?
PAIGE BAILEY: So TensorBoard is
a collection of different
visualization, you can see
scalers, accuracy, histograms,
you can see embedding
visualizers which allows you to
do a
great Mnist example from
TensorFlow a
couple years ago, it is
beautiful, and beholder, created
by a community member.
And the plugins, a couple of the
Google Summer of Code projects
this summer are focused on
getting additional visualization
plugins added to TensorBoard.
And so in addition to the what
if tool, and in addition to
beholder, you
can make your own TensorFlow
plugin.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: And what
while I'm geeking out about it
all day, I'm sure we need to
move to another question.  So
the next question that came in:
How
would you use future columns
with Keras?
PAIGE BAILEY: I know you know
the answer to this question.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: And it is a
passion of yours.  Feature
columns are a part of estimators
and are a way of getting your
data efficiently into
estimators, and with people
saying, like, hey, it is all
there in estimates, what about
Keras?
You have been working on great
stuff around that.
PAIGE BAILEY: And I know that
the
YouTube channel has a series
from Karmel.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: Karmel is the
engineering director for
high-level
APIs, she has a great series
around high level APIs for
TensorFlow, and is teaching
about that and her and her team
are working on parity for
columns on TensorFlow 2.  I have
not checked the alpha yet, but
it is on the way, if it is not
there already.  So you should be
able to use them in Keras.
PAIGE BAILEY: Yes, we are in the
process
of building out, if you wanted
to migrate your model, using
estimators to be more of a
TensorFlow 2.
0 with Keras, I'm in the process
of building a migration guide.
If you have any interest around
that, please feel free to reach
out and we're excited to get
that released pretty soon.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: I'm excited to
see that, personally, because
the very first
stuff I did in TensorFlow was
with estimateers before I
learned Keras, and I wanted to
change them to use Keras without
re-writing them.
PAIGE BAILEY: Absolutely, Keras
is just friendlier to work with,
I feel.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: They are both
greatest estimators, and Keras
is great for beginners, so
hopefully we will get the best
of both worlds.
So next question, Jeff Thomas,
looking for data sets for
testing and comparing different
training methods.
Looking for new data sets, like
MNIST
is great, but after a while,
people want something new.  So
what could you tell Jeff?
PAIGE BAILEY: We can tell him
about TensorFlow data sets!
LAWRENCE MORONEY: And there's a
blog post about it.
PAIGE BAILEY: It is about
creating the data ingestion
pipelines for you to be able to
easily use a variety of data
sets with all of your deep
learning and machine learning
models with just a few lines of
code.
So if you are familiar with
skikit
learn, and all of this, it is
nifty data ingestion practices,
this feels very similar.  It is
easy to do, training and
testing, and verifications.
And we have an LOT of data sets
readily available for you right
now to go ahead and explore.
And another thing that I would
especially like to call out is,
um, a member of our community --
so anybody can make your data
famous, right? If you have a
data set that you are using on
your research lab, if you have,
like, a bright and shiny CSV,
that you think would be a cool
add to this section.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: I have never
used a
CSV called bright and shiny.
PAIGE BAILEY: Everybody uses
them, a
community manager, Andrew, an
undergraduate researcher at
Stanford,
added 200,000 of these to the
Stanford ML group, in less than
a day.
It is as simple as take the
template format for images or
for audio or
whatever you are using, add some
additional metadata for the data
set, change the types for the
features you are using with
that, and voila.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: You are off to
the races.
PAIGE BAILEY: And you can make
your data famous.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: A wonderful
thing about it, if you are
getting started or
if you are learning, if you look
at the samples, pre-TensorFlow
data sets, you get a lot of code
about downloading the data,
unzip it here, relabel it like
this, put the files in these
folders, take a CSV and make
these features, but it is one or
two lines of code and the
training is set into data and
test sets for you, that type of
thing.
So for learners, I found it
exciting because I didn't have
to go through 100 lines of code
before I get to the neural
network.
PAIGE BAILEY: And also data
sciency
people, creating and training a
model is understanding the
shape, format, and the
statistical distributions, and
this is really helpful.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: Yep.  So
that's all we have time for.
We're going to take a break, we
will be taking some more of your
questions during the break.
And then we will be back in just
a few minutes to start answering
them.  Thanks very much.
[Music].
.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: Welcome back
everybody to the live stream
where Paige and I are answering
questions that you posted on
social media, on the live chat,
Stack Overflow, and anywhere
else you can find them.
If you have questions, please
hashtag #AskTensorFlow.
PAIGE BAILEY: And if we do not
answer your questions today, we
will in further sessions, so
keep asking, even if we
don't necessarily get to them.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: There are so
many that we cannot get to them
there today, a great problem to
have.  We have a show, Ask
TensorFlow.  So we will put
these questions into
the show, so please asking and
this is
what keeps the community
engaged.
So the first question, the
pre-built binary for GPU on 16?
PAIGE BAILEY: That is very
specific.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: I like
specific
questions, even if I can't
answer them.  So the pre-built
binaries for
TensorFlow tend to be associated
with a
specific driver for
NVIDIA.  So if you are looking
at any of the pre-built
binaries, look at what version
of the driver you have
supported.
I'm not an expert on NVIDIA
cards, and if you go over here,
like on my laptop, I have -- I
have called up, like, some
of the what NVIDIAs say about
the
TensorFlow system requirements,
and the
specific versions of the drivers
they support.
And one gotcha that I found in
working with GPUs is it is
easier to go to the driver
vendor and download the latest
version, but that is not one
that TensorFlow is built for
that it supports.
So make sure that they actually
match each other, you should be
good to go even with that
particular card.
PAIGE BAILEY: If you have warm
feelings and excitement for
builds for
TensorFlow, we have an interest
group, Sync build.  So please go
to the community section
of our GitHub and check up the
listserv and joining it in and
joining our weekly stand-up.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: Right.  So
thanks, Arthur, for that
question.
And then the next question is a
really funny one.  How many
times have you been asked this
today?
PAIGE BAILEY: At least 12.  At
least, and then the other flavor
of
it is, is this symbol that I use
all the time, is this supported
in TensorFlow 2.0, and if not,
what has changed?
LAWRENCE MORONEY: Yep.
And I -- I mean, people have
invested so much time in 1.
x, they don't want it to be
deprecated or go away.
So do scripts for 1 work with 2?
PAIGE BAILEY: The sad fact is
probably not.  They would not
work with TensorFlow 2.0 out of
the box.
But, we have created an upgrade
utility to use, it is
automatically downloaded with
TensorFlow 2.0 when you download
it, and you can check out what
it is doing in this
Medium blog post that I and my
colleague, Ana, created, as well
as this TensorFlow 2.0 video,
and the gifs, the best
communication medium possible,
shows you how you can use the
upgrade script on an N file.
So any, sort of, arbitrary
Python file
or Jupyter notebooks, a machine
learning IDE extension that
allows you to do that as well.
And it will give you an export.
text file that shows you the
symbol
renames and the manual changes
if you have to add them.  And
usually you do not.  So to see
it in action, you can take a
look at this particular text
generation
example that we have running a
Shakespeare, well, take all of
the corpus of Shakespeare text,
trains it
against the Shakespeare text,
and generates something that he
could have potentially written,
should he have had
access to deep learning
resources.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: I know you
all, and I
will up hold the wildest humor
of your idle dream.
PAIGE BAILEY: I didn't know you
knew Shakespeare.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: I played Henry
the IV.
PAIGE BAILEY: I was in much ado
about nothing.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: So while we
are on
much ado about nothing, the
Jupyter
notebook.
PAIGE BAILEY: Export the Python
file, and to reupgrade it.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: You have to
reconnect
the run.
PAIGE BAILEY: So starting it.
And the requirements, we can
check
that we are using TensorFlow
alpha, and like I mentioned
before, all you have to
do is preface this was a bang,
the name of the Python file is
text generation, and I wanted to
create an upgrade, shift
enter, and it does its upgrading
magic and, very quickly, it
tells me all of the things that
we need to change in order to
make it 2.
0 compatible and create that
file for me off to the side.  So
if I wanted to run this model,
it should be able to -- it
should be able to train as it
would.
So let's just check to make sure
that that would be the case.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: I think a lot
of the errors you are seeing
here, it is renamed APIs rather
than breaking changes within the
APIs as well.
PAIGE BAILEY: This is true.
You have re-names and additional
key words.  So for more
information about that,
and to see it running
in a video, you can go and take
a look there.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: Sounds good,
and you
have some gifs in there?
PAIGE BAILEY: Absolutely.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: And any jifes
for those that don't say gifs?
PAIGE BAILEY: It is in the
works.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: [ Laughter ],
so when it comes to upgrade,
there's a few little gotchas, so
hopefully the blog
post, the videos, will help you
get around them.
PAIGE BAILEY: And the community
you are mentioning before, we
had such an interest in testing
TensorFlow 2.0 and trying it out
against historic models that
we've formed a weekly testing
stand-up, and also we have a
migration support hour that is
being implemented with the
internal support hour.
So if you have an external group
that
is interested in upgrading your
model, please join the testing
group and we can get you
situated.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: And a lot of
the stuff
that we have seen in Keras, you
have the great slide where she
is training --
PAIGE BAILEY: The code is
exactly the same.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: Exactly the
same.  So while there is stuff
changing under the hood, a lot
of the surface-level code that
you are writing in Keras is not
changing.
PAIGE BAILEY: If you are used
Keras, you are probably not
going to have any problems.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: So good stuff.
Should we move on to the next
question? So I know we can talk
about 2.0 all day, but we just
mentioned Keras, and it appears.
PAIGE BAILEY: So I guess I can
ask you this question.  What is
the purpose of keeping
estimators in Keras as separate
APIs, is there something native
to Keras models that allows for
distributed training, or train
and evaluate?
LAWRENCE MORONEY: The purpose of
keeping them, there are many
purposes.  So for me, the main
purpose that I would like to
think of is, because a lot of
people are using them.
PAIGE BAILEY: Including internal
Google
teams that would tar and feather
us if we removed them [ laughter
].
LAWRENCE MORONEY: And so, when
it comes to estimators,
estimators are really great for
large-scale training.
PAIGE BAILEY: Yes.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: And it is like
a lot of times, you are doing
the large scale training, keep
going with estimators, they are
great.  When I first started
with TensorFlow, I started with
estimators, I could not figure
out what a node was in a neural
network and all of these
concepts that I had to learn,
where I had a simple estimator
that I can use to do a DNN or
something like that.  And so,
you know, they are there for a
reason and they are the same for
the reason.  Keras is one of the
things that, from the point of
view of making life easier for
developers that we have been
doubling down on TensorFlow 2,
and the code is the same between
1 and 2, and if -- the layers
API makes it super simple for
you to design a neural network,
and the fact that you can go low
level
beyond that, you know, to define
your
own layers allows you to drive
stick rather than automatic.
PAIGE BAILEY: And what is
beautiful about Keras 2.0 is you
have Keras the way you are used
to using it, and if you want
customizations, there's a
sub-component, if you wanted to
go lower, we have something
called TS module and we have
even exposed some of the basic,
most core ops in TensorFlow as
well.  So, at any sort of level
you want to interact with the
API, you can.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: Yep, and I
think there is another part of
the question that is around
distributed training.  So you
can scroll down there, and there
is something called distributed
strategy.
PAIGE BAILEY: Yep.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: With Keras and
with TensorFlow 2, and the whole
idea behind that is you can
distribute your training, maybe
across multiple GPUs on the same
machine, maybe across multiple
GPUs on different machines, and
maybe
across CPUs all over the place.
So distribution strategy is a
part of that, to help you with
that.  So estimators in Keras,
we love them both, they are
still there, and hopefully this
is something that will help you
with a question.  I think we
have time for just one more.
PAIGE BAILEY: Absolutely.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: Oh, this is a
Paige question.
PAIGE BAILEY: This is totally a
me question.  I'm the Python
person.  So ask TensorFlow, when
will
TensorFlow be supported in
Python 3.
7 and be accessed in Anaconda3?
I can answer Python 3.7, and I
would love to speak a little bit
more about support for Python
going forward.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: Please,
please.
PAIGE BAILEY: So, to answer the
3.7 question, I'm going to
bounce over to the TensorFlow 2.
0 project tracker, and these are
all of the standing issues that
we have when doing development
for TensorFlow 2.0, it is
transparent --
LAWRENCE MORONEY: You can see
your avatar.
PAIGE BAILEY: I have filed many
issues and they are transparent
to the public.  If you want a
context on where we stand
currently and what we have yet
to
do, this project tracker is a
great way to understand that.
And please take a look at 3.7
and, there we go.
In process of releasing binaries
for Python 3.5 and 3.
7, we issued 25, 420, it is
going off the screen, and 4.29.
You can take a look at that
issue and
it is currently in progress,
there is not really an eta, but
something that we want complete
by the time that the Alpha RC is
released.  So that is wonderful
to see.  And there is also, um,
a website
called Python three statements,
I think it is Python3statements.
com, maybe it is .org.  There we
go!
LAWRENCE MORONEY: Yay.
PAIGE BAILEY: Cool.  TensorFlow
made the commitment as of
January 1, 2020, we no longer
support Python 2 and we have
done that with a plethora of our
Python community.
So TensorFlow, Scikit-learn,
etc.
, we are committed to Python 3
and Python 3 support.
So you will -- you will be
getting your Python 3 support
and we are firmly committed to
having that.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: And a nice
thing about
the issue tracker is it is not a
big,
hey, we have it, coming to a
random point in the future, it
is transparent and you can see
what we are doing.
PAIGE BAILEY: And you can see
our people
commenting and the engineers
commenting back, yeah, man, I
was running it last
night, one more test and it is
it.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: That is all we
have time for, and remember,
#AskTensorFlow
on Twitter, Stack Overflow,
YouTube.
PAIGE BAILEY: Send a carrier
pigeon if that's your preferred
method of communication.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: I prefer owls.
PAIGE BAILEY: Owls are awesome.
LAWRENCE MORONEY: If you have
questions, we will do the best
to answer them, we will put a
lot on YouTube.com/TensorFlow.
So don't forget to subscribe,
thank you so much for being
engaged.
PAIGE BAILEY: Thank you.
[Music].
Often I hear sometimes from
researchers,
I really only do research and
care about training the machine
learning model and I don't mean
these instruments.
What I would argue is research
often leads to production and
where we want to
avoid is researchers having to
reimplement their hard work in
the model
they have work when they want to
put the model into the
production.
We really want the research
community
to build the models and the
framework in the community.
A second comment that I hear
often is
well, I only -- and all are
built to scale up. I don't
really need all of these heavy
tools. What we have seen time
and time again
at Google, is small data today
becomes large data tomorrow.
There is really no reason why
you would
have to reimplement your entire
stack because just your dataset
grew. We want to make sure you
can use the same tools early on
in your journey so the tools can
grow with you and your product
with the data so that you can
scale the exact same code to
hundreds of machines.
We are built TensorFlow Extended
and it
has had a profound impact in how
we do
production and becoming an AI
first company.
TFX powers some of the most
important alphabet companies.
It is used at six different
alphabet companies and within
Google it is used with all of
the major products and all
of the products that don't have
billions of users. I said before
we want to make TFX available to
all of you because we have seen
the profound impact it has had
on our business and we are
really excited to see what you
can do with the same tools in
your companies. A year ago, we
talked about the libraries that
we had open sourced at that
point in time.
We talked about TensorFlow
transform,
the training libraries,
estimators, and keras, and
TensorFlow Serving. I made the
point that back then, as today,
all of these are just libraries.
They are low-level libraries you
have to use independently and
stitch together
to make use and trend for your
own
use-casesuse-cases.
We added TensorFlow validation
later that year. It was valuable
to release these
libraries because some of our
most
important partners externally
have had a huge impack. Airbnb
uses TensorFlow server and our
friends at Twitter published a
fascinating blog post of how
they use
TensorFlow to rank tweets on
their home
timeline and used it to analyze
data and
used TensorFlow Hub to share the
word embeddings they used for
these models.
Coming back to this picture, for
those
who saw my talk last year, I
promised everyone there would be
more.
This is just a set of libraries
right now. Today for the very
first time, we are sharing the
horizontal layers that
integrate all of these libraries
into
one end platform into one end
program called TensorFlow
Extended.
First, we have to build
components.
At the top in orange are
libraries from the past and in
blue is current libraries.
Libraries are low level and
flexible.
We can build many components
part of the machine learning
pipeline.
I will go into detail in each
one of
these components later. A
component is no longer just a
library.
It is a package binary or
container that can be run as
part of a pipeline.
It is well defined input and
outputs. In the case of model
validation, it is
the last validated model.
A new candidate model and
validation. It has a well
defined configuration and most
importantly it is one
configuration model for the
entire pipeline.
You can figure a TFX pipeline
end-to-end. Some of you may have
noticed because
model validation needs to last,
it needs context and needs to
know what was the
last model validated. We need to
add a metadata store that keeps
a record of previous runs so SH
of
the more advanced capabilities
can be enabled.
How does this context get
created? The trainer produces
new model, the
model validator knows about the
last validated model and
candidate model and downstream
we take the new candidate
model and validation outcome and
if the out' come is positive we
push to the server and if it
isn't we don't because
we tonight  --
don't want to push a model that
is not neter. The metadata store
is new. When most people talk
about machine learning learn
floes and pipelines they think
about task dependency and think
about one component and when
that is finished there is
another component that runs.
However, all of you who do
machine learning in production
know we need data dependencies
because all components consume
and create artifacts and as the
example of model validation has
showed,
it is incredibly important to
know these dependency. We need a
system that is task and data
aware so each component has a
history of all the previous runs
and knows about all of the
artifacts. What is in this
metadata store? Most
importantly, type definitions of
artifact and their properties.
For TFX, it contains the
definition of all artifacts that
have been consumeed and produced
by components and all of their
properties.
It is an extensible type system
and you can add new properties
to the artifacts if you need to
track more properties of those.
Secondly, we keep a record of
all of the execution of the
components.
With that execution, we store
all of the
imported
artifact and the output
artifacts that were produced and
the Runtime components.
If you want to track the code
snapshot, you can store it in
the metadata store as well.
Putting these things together
allows us to do something called
linear tracking across all
executions. If you know every
execution, all inputs
and outputs, you can piece
together a
story of how an artifact was
created.
We can say what were the
upstreams that went into
producing the artifact and what
were the downstream runs
artifacts
that were produced using the
artifact as an input. That is a
powerful capability and let
me talk you through some of the
examples of what this enables.
The first is pretty
straightforward. Let's say I
want to list all of the training
runs I are done in the past. I
am interested in the trainer and
I want to see all the training
runs that were recorded.
In this case I had two training
run and see all the properties.
This is pretty straightforward
and nothing new to see here. We
can visualize the lineage and
all the information we have. The
first comment on this slide is
we are working on a better UI.
This is just for demonstration
purposes.
If you look at the end of the
graph, you see the model expert
path.
This is the specific instance of
the model that was created and
we see the model was created by
the trainer and the
trainer created this model by
consuming a schema, transform
and examples. These are specific
instances so the IDs are not
just number.
They are schema of ID number 4
and for
each of those artifact WEEZsee
they were created upstream.
This allows forward and backward
in the
artifact and the narrative I
used was walking back from the
model but you
could look at training data and
say were what the artifacts
produced using that training
data.
This slide shows a visualization
of the data distribution that
went into the model.
At first glance, this may not be
something like that that is
earth shattering because we have
done this before. We can compute
and visualize statistics but if
you look at the code snippet, we
are fought referring data or
statistics.
We are referring to a model.
We say show me the distribution
of data the model was trained on
and we can do this because we
have a track record of all the
data and statistics that went
into this model. We can do a
similar thing in the other
direction saying for a specific
model show me the sliced metrics
that were produced downstream by
TensorFlow model
analysis and we can get this
visualization again just by
looking at a model and not
specifically pointing to the
output of TensorFlow analysis.
We know all the models that were
trained
and where the checkpoints lie so
we can
start support to the historic
runs and look at the tensor port
for the models you have trained
in the past.
Because we have a track record,
you can
launch tensor point and compare
two models in the same instance.
This is really model tracking
and experiment comparison after
the fact. We enabled this by
keeping a track record of all of
this.
If you have multiple models, you
can look at the data
distribution for multiple models
and this usually helps with
debugging a model. If you train
the same model twice, or
on data and it behaves
differently, sometimes it can
pay off. We are overlaying two
distributions of the statistics
for one model and the
other and you would see if there
is a considerable drift between
those two.
All of these are enabled by this
lineage tracking.
Another set of use-cases is
visualizing previous runs over
time. So if you train the same
model over time over new data we
can give you a time series graph
of all metrics over time and you
can see if your model improves
or gets worse over time as you
re-train it. Another powerful
use case is carrying over state
from previous models because we
know you have trained the model
in the past we can do something
called warm starting. We can
reinitialize the model with
weights from a previous run.
Sometimes you want to
reinitialize the entire model or
just an embedding and in this
way we can continue training
from
where we left off with a new
dataset.
And another very powerful
application
of this is being able to reuse
previously outputed outputs.
If you have a pipeline that
ingest data, applies
transformation to data and
then you train the model, every
time you make a small change to
the model you don't want to
recompute every upstream. There
is no reason just because you
changed something in the model.
Because we have a track record
of all the previous steps, we
can make a decision of saying
your data hasn't changed, your
transfer code hasn't changed and
we will reuse the artifacts that
produced the upstream and you
can iterate much, much faster.
This improves iteration speeds
and saves
compute because you are not
reexot  -- recomputing things
you already computed in the
past.
We talked about components and
how do we orchestrate TFX
pipelines? Every component has
something we call a driver and
publisher. The driver's
responsibility is to basically
retrieve state from the metadata
store to inform what work needs
to be done. In the example of
model validation, the
driver looks into the metadata
store to
find the last validated model.
The publish keeps the record of
everything going in the
component, produced and Runtime
configuration so we
can do the lineage tracking I
mentioned earlier.
In between is the executer who
is unaware of the metadata
because it is important to make
that piece relatively simple
because if you want to change
the training code in a component
you should not have to worry
about drivers and publishes,
just the executer. It makes it
easier to write new
components for the system, also.
We have one shared configuration
model
on top that configures
end-to-end pipeline.
As you can see this is a Python
dsl,
you see it has an object for
each component from top to
bottom.
The training component you can
see basically receives
configuration and
says your input come from the
transer outoutput and the schema
that was inferred.
Let's see what is inside the of
the trainer and that is really
just TensorFlow code.
We use an estimator and an
estimator train and evaluate
method to train this model.
It takes an estimator and we
just use one of our pre-made
estimators.
This is a wide and deep model
you can instantiate and return.
We don't have an opinion on what
this code looks like. It is just
TensorFlow.
Anything that produces a safe
model as output is fair game.
You can use a keras model that
produces an inference graph or
if you chose to you can use
lower level APIs in TensorFlow
as long as it produces a safe
model in the right format that
it can be useded in TensorFlow
or for model analysis, you can
write any type of TensorFlow
code you want.
So, if you have noticed, we
still haven't talked about
orchestration.
We are a configuration,
components and metadata store. I
know some of you might be
thinking is he going to announce
a new orchestration system and
the good news is no. At least
not today.
Instead we talked to a lot of
users and
unsurprisingly found out that
there is a significant install
base of
orchestration systems in your
companies. We just heard from
Airbnb, of course they developed
airflow and there is a
lot of companies that use
Kubeflow and there is a number
of other orchestration systems.
We made the choice to select any
number
of orchestration systems because
we don't want to make you adopt
a new
orchestration system to use the
TFX pipelines.
Reason number two is we want you
to extend TFX pipelines.
We published our version of what
a TFX pipeline looks like and
the components we use at Google,
but we want to make it easy for
you to add components before,
after and in parallel to
customize the pipeline to your
own use-cases.
All these orchestrations are
made to be able to express
arbitrary workflows and if you
are familiar withing of those
orchestration systems you should
be able to use them for a use
case. Here are two examples of
what it looks like with airflow
and Kubeflow pipelines.
On the left you see the same TFX
pipeline configured that is
executed on AirFlow.
In the Chicago taxi cab example
we used 10,000 records.
On the right side you see the
same
pipeline executed on Kubeflow on
data Cloud so you can scale it
up to the 100 million rows in
that dataset.
It is the same configuration and
components running in both
environments and you can chose
how you want to orchestrate them
in your own favorite
orchestration system.
This is what this looks like if
it is put together.
TFX goes all the way from raw
data to your deployment
environment. We discussed a
shared configuration model at
the top.
The metadata system that keeps
track of the runs no matter how
you orchestrator
the component and two ways to
publish them with airflow and
Kubeflow but you can chose to
orchestrate the TFX pipeline in
any way you want.
All of this is available now so
you can
go on
GitHub/TensorFlow/TFX.
Tomorrow we have a workshop
where you
can get hands on experience with
TensorFlow Extended and there is
no
prerecks and you don't to bring
your own laptop.
We will jump into an example
with the Chicago taxicab
dataset.
This is a record of cab rides in
Chicago for some period of time.
It contains everything you would
expect. It contains when the
trip started, when it ended,
where they started and ended,
how much was paid for it and how
it was paid.
Some of the features need
transformation so longitude and
latitude
features need to be packaged.
We treat them as categorical
features.
Strings need to be integerized
and some
of the flows need to be
normalized.
We feed the dense features into
the deep part and all the others
use the wide part.
The label we are trying to
predict is a bullion which is if
the tip is larger than 20% of
the fare. Really, what we are
doing is building a
high tip predictor just in case
if there
is any cab drivers in the
audience or online, come find me
later. I think this will be
beneficial to you if you can
predict if a cab ride give as
high tip or not. Let's jump in
and start with data validation
transformation. The first part
of the TFX pipeline is ingesting
data, validating that data if
it is OK, and then transforming
so it
can be fed into a TensorFlow
graph.
We start with the
examplexamplegenwhich
takeexamplegen. This is
extensible.
You can ingest any type of data
in the pipelines. What is
important is after the step the
data is in a well defined place
where we
can find it, in a well defined
format because all downstream
components standardize and it is
split between training and
develop.
You have seen the configuration
of these components before.
It is very minimal configuration
in most of the cases.
Next we move on to data analysis
and validation. I think a lot of
you have a good intuition of why
it is important. Machine
learning is the process of
taking data and learning models
that predict some field in your
data and you are always aware if
you feed garbage in you get
garbage out.
There is no hope in learning a
good machine learning if the
data is wrong or has errors in
them.
This is reinforced if you have
continuous pipelines produced on
data from a bad model and you
are reinforcing the same
problem.
Data understanding is critical
for model understanding.
There is no hope in
understanding why a model isn't
predicting something if the data
isn't right.
The question you may ask as a
cab
driver is why are trip
predictions bad
in the morning hours and I will
try to
answers these with the TFX
toolsets we V. There is a lot of
care taking with code.
It is previewed, checked into
repository, version controlled
and data needs to be first-class
citizens in these systems. With
the question what are expected
values from payment types? That
is a question about the schema
of your data and what we would
argue is that the schema needs
to be treated with
the same care as you treat your
code. And catching errors early
is absolutely critical because I
am sure as all of you
know errors propagate thew the
system.
If the data is not OK, every
downstream goes wrong.
These errors are hard to fix if
you catch them late in the
process. Really catching those
problems as early as possible is
absolutely critical.
In the taxicab example, you
would ask a question is this new
company I have in
my dataset a typo or a real
company
which is a
natchal evolution of my dataset.
The statistics training program
takes in the data and it can be
training or
serving logs in which case you
can look at the skew between
serving and training data.
Statistics really capture the
shape of your data and the
visualization components draw
your attention to things that
need your attention such as if a
feature is missing most of the
time it is highlighted in red.
The configuration for this
component is minimal as well.
Let me zoom into some of these
visualizations. One question I
posted earlier was why
are my predictions bad in the
morning hours. You could look at
the dataset and see for trip
start hour in the morning hours
before 2:00-6:00 A.M. you don't
have much data because there
is not that much taxi trips at
that time
and not having a lot of data in
a specific area can mean your
model is not robust or has
higher variance and this
could lead to worse predictions.
Next schemagen.
It takes the output and infers a
schema for you.
There is very few features in
this case so you could handwrite
the schema. If you have
thousands of features, it
is hard to handwrite that
expectation so we infer the
schema for you and it represents
what you expect from your data
and what good data looks like
and what values your string
features can take on and so on.
Again, very minimal
configuration. The question we
can answer is what are expected
values for payment types. If you
look at the bottom, you see the
field payment type can cake ton
cash,
credit card, dispute, no charge,
p card and unknown.
Next time I run this, and this
field takes on a different
value, I will get
an anomaly which comes from the
example validator. The example
validator takes the statistics
and schema as input and produces
on anomaly report.
That anomaly report tell you if
the data
is missing feature, has the
wrong relevancey, if the
distribution has shifted and
deis important to highlight the
anomaly report is human readable
so you can look at it and
understand what
is going on but it is always
machine
readable so you can
automatically make
decisions on the
anomalanomaly. Here you can see
the field company has
taken on unexpected string
values.
That just means these string
values were not in your schema
before and that
can be a natural evolution of
data.
The first time you run it maybe
you
didn't see trips from those
taxicab companies but when you
look you see they are normal so
you can update or if you saw a
lot of scrambled text you would
know there is a problem in your
data that you would have to go
and fix.
Moving on, we actually get to
transform. Let me just recap the
types of transformations we want
to do.
I highlighted them in blue.
We want to convert the strings
to ints
and for the tense features we
want to normalize them. All of
these transformations require
you to do a full pass.
To pact  packatize you need to
figure out the boundaries. For a
string to int you need to see
all
the string values.
This is exactly what we build
TensorFlow transform for. It
allows you to express the
preprocessing function of your
data that contains some of these
transformations that require a
full pass of your data and
enable automatically to run the
data processing graph to compute
those statistics. In this case,
you can see the orange
boxes are statistics that we
require,
for minimalization we require a
mean and
standard deviation and
TensorFlow
transform says scale to C store
and it will create a data
processing graph for you that
will compute the standard mean
and data and return the results.
That graph is a hematic graph
that contains all the
information you need to apply
your transformations. That graph
can then be used in training and
surveying guaranteeing there is
no drift between them.
This
eliminates the chances of skew
and at
serving time you need to feed in
the raw data and all the
transformations are done as part
of a TensorFlow graph. The
transfer component takes in
data, the schema allows you to
parse the data,
and code in this case the system
provided preprocessing function,
and it
produces a hematic graph that
gets attached to your training.
It can materialize the transform
data
and that is a performance
optimization you need.
It can pay off to serialize some
of the training before the next
step.
The component takes in a module
file, a file where you configure
preprocessing function.
In this code snippet, the actual
code isn't important but I want
to highlight the last line in
this code snippet and that is
how we transform our label
because there label is a logic
expression of saying it is
greater than 20% of my fare. I
want to highlight this because
you don't need analyze phase for
all of your transformations.
In cases where you don't need
analysis phases, the
transformation is just a regular
TensorFlow graph.
To square something to C square
and integerize schemes you need
these phases.
This is the user code you would
write
and transfer creates the graph
and returns the transfer graph
you need to
apply these transformations.
Now we are done with this we
haven't trained a machine
learning model right but we have
made sure we know our data is in
a place where we can find it, it
is in a format we can understand
and split between training and
deval and we know our data is
good because we
validated them and we are
applying
transforms consistently between
training and serving.
This bringstuse the training
step.
This is where the magic happens.
The training steps is the
TensorFlow graph and step.
The training component takes in
the output of transform as
mentioned which is the transform
graph and optionally
the materialized data, schema
and
training codes that you provide.
It creates output to TensorFlow
models. Those models are in the
safe model
format the standard serialized
model in TensorFlow which you
heard quite a bit about this
morning. We produced two of
them. One is the inference graph
and another is the evaluate
graph which contains the metrics
and necessary annotations to
perform TensorFlow model
analysis. This is the
configuration you have seen
earlier and again the trainer
takes in a module file and the
code that is actually in that
module file, again, I am going
to show you the same slides to
reiterate the point is just
TensorFlow. In this case it is
the train and
evaluate method from estimators
and the estimator being returned
here.
Again, just to make sure you are
aware of this, any TensorFlow
code here that produces the safe
model in the right format is
fair game. This works really
well. With this, we have now
trained the TensorFlow model and
now I am going to hand it off to
my colleague Christina
who will talk about model
evaluation analysis.
-- model validation.
Thank you, Clemens. Hi, my name
is Christina and I am a software
engineer on the Google brain
team.
I am here today to tell you
about some tools my team and I
have built to help make the
end-to-end lifecycle of the
machine learning pipeline
easier. I am going to start by
talking about
model analysis and salad
validation. These are two
different components in
TFX but they are similar in how
they are executed. The main
difference is how you, as an end
user, will use them.
I will start by talking about
the evaluator. Why is this
important? We have gathered
data, cleaned that data, trained
a model, but we really want to
make sure that model works and
some model evaluation can help
you
assess the overall quality of
your model.
You also may want to analyze how
your model is performing on
specific Slices of the data. So,
in this case with the Chicago
taxi example that Clemens
started us off with, why are my
tip predictions sometimes wrong?
Slicing the data and looking at
where
you are doing poorly can be a
real benefit because it
identifies low-hanging fruit
where you can get
gains in accuracy by adding more
data,
or making some other changes to
make some of these segments
improve. You also want to track
your performance over time.
You are going to be continuously
training models and updating
them with fresh data so your
models don't get stale and you
want to make sure that your
metrics are improving over time
and
not regressing and model
evaluation with help with this.
The component of TFX that
supports this
is called
evaluator.
You need to specify the splits
in data
you find more interesting so the
evaluateator
evaluator. A process is run to
generate metric for the overall
slice and the Slices you have
specified.
The output of the evaluator is
evaluation metrics. This is a
structured data format that has
your data, the splits you
specified,
and the metrics that correspond
to each split.
The TensorFlow model analysis
library also has a visualization
tool that allows you to load up
these metrics and
dig around in your data in a
user-friendly way.
So going back to our Chicago
taxi example, you can see how
the model
evaluator can help you look at
your top-line objective and how
well can you
predict trips that result in
large tips.
The
TFMA visualization shows the
overall data.
Maybe you want to stay 95%
accuracy.
That is a lot better than 94.7.
Maybe you want to bump that up.
Then you can dig into why your
tip predictions are sometimes
wrong. We sliced the data by the
hour of the day the trip starts
on and sorted by poor
performance.
When I look at this data, I see
trips that start at 2-3:00 a.m.
were performing quite poorly in
these times. Because of the
statistics generation
tool Clemens talked about I know
the
data is sparse here but if where
didn't
I would think maybe there is
something
that people that get taxies
during that
time that causes erratic tipping
behavior.
You also want to know if you can
get
better at predicting trips over
time. You are continuously
training the model for new data
and hoping you get better. The
TensorFlow model analysis tool
that powers the evaluator in TFX
can show you
the trends of your metrics over
time. Here you see three
different models and
the performance over each with
accuracy and AU C.
Now I will move on to talking
about the model validator
component.
With the evaluator, you were an
active
user, you generated the metrics,
you loaded them up into the UI,
you dug around in your data, you
looked for issues you could fix
to improve your
model, but eventually you are
going to iterate, your data is
going to get better and model
improve and you will be ready to
launch. You will have a pipeline
continuously
feeding new data into this
model. Every time you generate a
new model with new data you
don't want to have to do a
manual process of pushing this
to a server somewhere.
The model validator component of
TFX acts as a gate that keeps
you from pushing bad versions of
your model while
allowing you to auto
automate pushing.
We want to avoid pushing models
with degrated quality
specifically in an automated
fashion. If you train a model
with new data and the
performance drops but say it
increases in certain segments of
the data you care about, maybe
you make the judgment call this
is an improvement call overall
so we will launch it.
But you don't want to do this
automatically you want to have
say before you do this. This
acts as your gatekeeper.
You want to avoid breaking
downstream
components if your model started
outputing something your server
binary couldn't handle you would
want to know that before you
push.
The TFX component that supports
this is called the model
validator taking similar input
and output to the model
evaluator and the libraries that
compute
the metrics are pretty much the
same
under the hood, however, you
provide two models.
It then runs on your eval split
data and
compares the metrics on the same
data between the two models. If
your metrics have stayed the
same or improved, you go ahead
and bless the model. If the
metrics that you care about have
degraded, you will not bless the
model, get some information
about which metrics failed so
you can do further analysis.
The outcome of this is a
valididation outcome.
It just says blessed if
everything went right.
Another thing to mote about the
model
validator is it allows next day
eval of your next day push.
Maybe the last model you
blessed, it was trained with old
data. With the model evaluator,
it evaluates it on the new data.
And finally, I am going to talk
about the pusher.
It pusher is probably the
simplest
component in the entire TFX
pipeline but it does serve quite
a useful purpose.
It has one input which is that
blessing
that you got from the model
validator.
Then the output is if you passed
your
validation then the pusher will
copy
your saved model into a file
system destination you have
specified.
Now you are ready to serve your
model and make it useful to the
world at-large.
I am going to talk about model
deployment next. So this is
where we are.
We have a trained saved model.
A saved model is a universal
serialization format for
TensorFlow models.
It contains your graph, your
learned
variable weights, your assets
like embeddings and vocabulary,
but to you this is just an
implementation detail. Where you
really want to be is you have
an API, you have a server that
you can query to get answers in
real-time or
provide those answers to your
users. We provide several
deployment options and many of
them are going to be
discussed at other talks in this
session.
TensorFlow.
js is optimized for serving in
the browser.
TensorFlow Lite is optimized for
mobile devices. We heard a talk
about how Google
Assistant is using TensorFlow
Lite to support model inference
on their Google Home devices.
TensorFlow Hub is something new.
Andr is going to come on in
five minutes and tell you about
that so I am
not going to step on his toes. I
am going at a talk about
TensorFlow Serving.
If you want to put up a resting
API you would want to use
TensorFlow Serving. Why would
you want to use this?
For one thing, TensorFlow
Serving has a lot of
flexibility.
It supports multi tenancy.
You can run multiple models on a
single server instance and run
multiple versions of the same
model. This can be useful when
you are trying to canary a new
model.
Say you have a tried and tested
version
of your model, you have created
a new
one, it past your evaluator and
validation but you want to do
testing with real users before
you completely switch over.
TensorFlow Serving supports
this.
We also support optimization
with GPU and TensorFlow RT.
You can expose a gRPC or REST
API. TensorFlow Serving is
optimized for
high performance.
It provides low let latency and
request
batching and traffic isolation
so if you are serving multiple
models on a single server, a
traffic spike in one of those
models won't affect the serving
of the other.
And TensorFlow Serving is
production ready, finally. This
is what we use to serve many of
our models inside of Google.
We have served millions of QPS
with it.
You can scale in minutes
particularly if you use the
Docker image and scale up on
Kubernetes.
We support dynamic version
refresh so you can specify a
version refresh policy to take
the latest version of your model
or you can pin to a specific
version.
This can be useful for rollbacks
if you find a problem with the
latest version
after you have already pushed. I
am going to go into a little bit
more detail about how you might
deploy a REST API for your
model.
We have two different options
for doing this.
The first, the top command, is
using Docker which we really
recommend. It requires a little
bit of ramp up at the beginning,
but you will really save time in
the long run by not having to
manage your environment and not
having to manage your own
dependencies.
You can run locally on your own
host but you have to do all that
stuff long term.
I will go into more detail on
the Docker run command.
You start with Docker run, chose
a port
you want to bind your API to,
provide
the path to the saved model
generated by your trainer and
hopefully it was pushed by the
pusher, you provide the model
name, and you tell Docker to run
the TensorFlow Serving binary.
Another advantage of using
Docker is
that you can easily enable
hardware
acceleration if you are running
on a
host with a GPU and Nvidia host
installed you can run on an
accelerated hardware.
If you need further optimization
we
support tensor RT which is
optimized for deep learning
inference. Your Chicago taxi
example that we have been using
here probably wouldn't benefit
from this but if you had an
image recognition model, ResNet,
you
could get performance boosting
and cost
savings by using TensorRT.
We provide a command line
allowing you to convert this
model and a simple change to the
command line and you are
running on accelerated GPU
hardware TensorRT optimization.
To put it all together again, we
introduced TensorFlow Extended
or TFX and showed you how the
different components that TFX
consist of can work together to
help you manage the
end-to-end lifecycle of your
machine learning pipeline.
First, you have your data and we
have tools to help you make
sense of that, process it, and
prepare it for training. We then
support training your model and
after you train your model we
provide tools that allow you to
make sense of what you are
seeing, of what your model is
doing and to make improvements,
also to make sure you don't
regress. Then we have the pusher
that allows you to push to
various deployment options
and make sure model available to
serve users in the real world.
To get started with TensorFlow
Extended, please visit us on
GitHub.
There is more documentation at
tensorflow.org/TFX and some of
my teammates are running a
workshop tomorrow and they would
love to see you there. You don't
need to bring a laptop. We have
machines setup and ready to go
and you can get hands-on
experience
using TensorFlow Extended. Thank
you. Please welcome Andr who
will talk about TensorFlow Hub.
Thank you, Christina.
Could I get the notes on the
presentation? Thank you. Hello.
My name is Andr and I am a
software engineer in Zurich and
I am the
technical lead for the
TensorFlow Hub project. It is a
library and project for using
machine learning.
We Open Sourced it last year.
Today I will give you an update
on the project. Let's start by
talking about when you want to
use it.
If you have problems collecting
enough
data to train models from
scratch than this is for you.
Additionally, since it is so
easy to reuse computations and
weights, it becomes possible to
leverage features
without having to learn how to
fit them into neural networks.
Images, text and videos are
features you can use with a
single line of code.
You might also have encountered
problems where codebases become
really coupled
and experimentation becomes
slower over time.
By defining an artifact that
does not depend on code, hub
allows for more
maintainable systems similar to
how libraries help software
engineers.
The main concept is this
pre-trained
building blocks that we call
modules. Typically we start by
training a large model with the
right algorithm and data. From
this large model, we are
interested in just a part which
is reusable.
This is typically a bottleneck
layer or disrooted
representation.
Then we can package them into a
saved
model that defines the
commutation and
no longer depends on the
original code.
You can share with web servers,
cloud and artifact system. You
can bring the module back as a
piece of a new model to solve a
new task.
Since the model is defined by
TensorFlow primitives you can
fine tune
the waits  weights and adjust
them. For the last few months,
we have been making it easier to
use. This concept of saving a
part of the model and loading it
back is getting integrated right
in the core of TensorFlow.
We have added saveModel features
that make it possible to share
more than just
signatures and with eager
execution it
becomes even easier to select
the part the network that gets
exports. Let's look at a few
examples. In TensorFlow 2.
0, we can load a module with
hub.load. We can use tf.saved
model.
load if it is on the system.
Once loaded, we can call it
right away.
Due to the new capabilites you
can share any object composed of
TensorFlow primitives. Text
features has two members. Call
which is a TFX function and
embedding which is a TF
variable. We are really excited
that we added
support for polymorphic
functions on saved model. This
will provide a more natural
interface than we had before
with signatures. Here we see an
image representation
module being loaded and being
used in inference mode or used
during training mode where batch
mode is on. When it is on, we
can control some of its
parameters.
This is just backed by TF graphs
so we no longer need to be
selecting things here and there.
We just get the API that looks
very like Python.
Additionally, we have added the
new symbol. Hub.keraslayer. This
makes integrating hub models
into a keras model easier.
In this example, we see how easy
it is
to build a text sentence -- a
sentence classification model.
We have three layers.
The top model is this keras
layer, is a
layer that receives inputs and
outputs representation. Then we
have a dense layer and a
classification layer.
Since the keras layer with this
MLM layer, we can just feed
sentences straight into the
model. We never have to define
the logic.
If we wanted to try other text
models we
could just change that string.
That is the easiest way to try
the new research.
We have released 0.3 version of
TensorFlow Hub. We have hub.load
and hub.keraslayer and they are
usable in TensorFlow 2.0 both in
eager and in graph mode.
To let you preview this
functionality, we have published
modules in this format and the
next step for us is to backport
existing models.
A bit more practical now.
Google AI and DeepMind teams
have been
sharing information on
tfhub.dev.
This was launched last year.
One of the most popular was the
universal sentence encoder.
This encoded short sentences
into a vector that could be used
for many natural language tasks.
The team added a cross-lingual
version of these. Sentences with
similar meaning,
independent of the language, end
up in points close together. You
can learn the classifier using
English data and you could run
it on other languages.
We have also added image
augmentation models.
They have been shown to transfer
to new tasks. An interesting
thing is you could grab
this module and one of the image
representation modules and you
could string them together. The
image augmentation model would
reduce the amount of data by
data augmentation and the image
feature
vector by transfer learning.
There are many more.
We have BERT model for tasks, we
have biggan models and more.
Some were designed especially
for low resources.
Additionally, we have been
working to make the modules more
integrated.
We have a common line utility to
convert the hub model into TF
model.
It can be used with a library
for ML
and they can also be used inside
TF transform.
If you want to try it you can go
to
tfhub.dev. Most of them include
the link where you can see them
in action. Thank you.
Thank you very much. OK.
Now you have all learned
hopefully training neural
networks that if I show up there
is food.
So, we are going to come back
here at 4:45 to do a little wrap
up. The wrap up session is going
to be amazing not that this
wasn't also amazing. We will be
talking about probablyability,
reinforcement learning, we will
be talking about -- Elena is
coming back to tell us about her
stuff. It is going to be great.
After that there is a party.
Please stay with us. Come back.
Don't forget to go upstairs and
check out the demos. Thank you
so much.
Aida net
et
AdaNet
da net
auto M L
test test test test
Extreme weather is changing.
There is more extreme rainfall,
heavy flooding, forest fires.
Being able to predict these
extreme
events more accurately is the
biggest changes we are facing.
There is 100 Tarabytes every
day. Climate data is a big
problem.
We need things that are fast and
can sift through the data
accurately and rapidly.
Deep learning is poised for
problems in climate science.
A lot of
NERSC are using TensorFlow. We
use TensorFlow to layer and to
create the deep learning model,
we started from segmentation
models which
have proven to be successful and
we use
TensorFlow to enhance the models
until
we found a set of models that
perform well enough for the
specific task.
The network required 14
teraflops. If you want to do
this on your work
station, it would take months to
train.
It takes the largest
computational resources on the
planet. Two tennis courts in
size, this computer is
state-of-the-art and a million
times faster than your common
laptop. 3.3 exaflops.
Imagine what you do at your work
station and imagine having
27,000 times that power. We can
do that now.
We were surprised how good it
scales.
2,000 nodes, 5,000 nodes.
This was the first time anyone
has ran
an AI application at this scale.
The climate scientists could
express
things in Python in TensorFlow
and get all the code people are
used to.
We are entering a state where AI
can
contribute to the predictions of
these
extreme weather events.
We can tackle things we never
thought. Understanding diseases
like Alzheimer's and cancer.
That is like incredible.
We have shown with a PRAM work
like
TensorFlow you can get to
massive scale and accomplish
goals.
Genetics, neuroscience, physics
-- that
is immensely exciting for me.
-- framework --
[Applause]
Hello, everyone.
I am Josh Dillon and I am a lead
on the TensorFlow Probability
team and today I will talk about
probability stuff and how it
relates to TensorFlow stuff.
Let's find out what that means.
OK.
These days machine learning
often means specifying deep
model architectures and
fitting them under loss and
keras makes specifying this
architecture easily but what
about the loss?
Choosing the right loss is
tough.
Improving even a reasonable one
it be tougher.
Once you fit the model, how do
you know it is good?
Why not use entropy or mode?
Wouldn't it be nice if there was
a plug and play with keras and
the rest of TF model?
This would make comparing models
easier
by maximizing likelihood and
having as
it SKT -- rapidly available
statistics we can reject the bad
ones and accept the good ones.
Wouldn't it be great to say I
want to maximize the log
likelihood and summarize what I
learned easily and in a unified
way. Let's play with that idea.
Here we have a dataset.
These blue dots and our task is
to
predict, pretend task, is to
predict the
Y coordinate from the X
coordinate.
You might do this by specifying
a deep
model and choosing the mean
squared error as the loss
function.
But our wish here is to think
probalistically and that means
maximizing the log likelihood
like here with this Lambda
function. We want to get back a
distribution, a thing that has
attached to it statistics we can
use to evaluate what we just
learned.
If only such a thing were
probably.
Of course, it is and you can do
this now. Using TensorFlow
Probability
distribution layers you can
specify the
model as part of your deep net.
The loss now is actually part of
the model, sort of the way it
used to be,
the way it is meant to be. We
have two dense layers.
The second one outputs one float
that
is parameterizing a normal
distrubution
mean through this distribution
Lambda layer. Being we are able
to find this line,
that looks great, and the best
part is once we instantite this
model with test points we have
back a distribution for
which you get not just the mean
but intropy variance and
standard deviation and all these
things.
You can compare between this and
other
distributions as we will see
later -- entropy. If we look at
the data, something is fishy
here, right? Notice as the
magnitude of X increases,
the
variance of my increases also.
What can we do to fix this?
Answer? Learn the variance too.
If we are fitting a normal why
on earth
do we think the variance would
be one? That is what you are
doing when you use mean squared
error.
To achieve this, all I had to do
was make my previous layer
output two floats. Passing one
to the mean as normal, one
in as the standard deviation of
the normal, and press no change
and now I
have learned the standard
deviation from the data itself.
That is what the green lines
are.
This is cool because if you are
a
statistician, it means you are
learning known unknowns.
The data had variance and you
learned
it and it cost you basically
nothing to do but a few key
strokes. The way you saw to do
this was self evident from the
fact you were using a normal
distribution for a curious
constant sitting there.
This is good but I don't know is
there enough data for which we
can claim this
red line is the mean and the
green lines
are the standard deviation? How
would we know? Is there anything
else we can do? Of course there
is. A keras dense layer has two
components. A kernel matrix and
a bias vector.
What makes you think those point
estimates are the best
especially given your dataset
itself is random and
possibly inadequate to
meaningfully and reliable learn
those estimates. You can learn a
distribution over
weight, this is the same as
learning an
ensemble that is
infinitely large.
As you can see, all I had to do
was replace keras.
dense with with dense variation.
The keyword here -- I like to
think of the unknowns unknowns.
As a consequence, of course,this
means
any model or instantiation is a
random variable because the
weight is a random available.
That is why you see all the
lines, there
are many lines, we have an
ensemble of them but if you
averaged them and took the
standard deviation that would
give you an estimate of credible
intervals over your prediction
and you can go to
your customer and say here is
what I think will happen and
this is how much you can trust
me.
We lost the head
-- I just output two floats and
feed that into my output layer
and press no change. I am
learning both known and unknown
knowns and all it cost me was a
few key strokes.
So what you see here is an
ensemble of
standard deviations associated
with the known-unknown parts,
the variances observable in the
Y axis, as well as a
number or ensemble of these mean
regressions. OK. That's cool. I
like where this is going but I
have to ask what makes you think
a line is even the right thing
to fit here? Is there another
distribution we could chose? A
richer distribution that would
actually find the right form of
the data?
Of course the answer is yes.
It is a
Galsian process.
The
Gaussian process can see this.
How can you do that if you are
specifying mean squared error as
your loss? You can't.
It has to be part of the model.
When you bake these ideas into
one model
you get to move it around
fluidly between weight
uncertainty and variance in the
data and even uncertainty in the
loss function you are fitting
itself.
So the question is, how can this
all be so easy?
How did it fit together? With
TensorFlow Probability.
TensorFlow Probability is a
collection
of tools designed to make
probalistic reasoning in
TensorFlow easier. It is not
going to make your job easy. It
is just going to give you the
tools you need to express the
ideas you have. You still have
to have domain knowledge
and expertise but you can encode
that in a
probalistic
formulism and TensorFlow Hub has
the way to do that.
Gone are the days of hacking a
model in
R and importing it to a faster
language. If you predict the
light is green, you
better be confident you should
go.
You can do that with probalistic
modeling and TensorFlow
Probability.
We saw one small part of TFP.
The tools are broken into two
components.
Those tools use FWL -- for
building
models and those useful for do
analyzing.
It is summary statistics like it
is in other libraries.
Our distributions support batch
shape but for the most part they
should be pretty natural and
easy to use. We also have
something we call bijectors
which is a library for
transforming random variables.
This can be like taking the X of
a normal and now you have a log
normal.
In comply
-- complicated cases it is like
mascots, regressive flows, MVPs
and
other
sophisticated probalistic
models. Edward2 helps you
combine different variables as
one.
On the inference side, no
library would be compete without
Monte Carlo tools.
We have transitions components
one is
called Markov chain Monte Carlo
and variational inference tools.
And of course we have our own
optimizers that come up.
The point is this toolbox has
maybe not everything but
certainly it has most of
what you might need to do
fancier modeling to get more. It
doesn't have to be hard.
You saw the keras examples were
sequences of one-line changes.
Of course, TensorFlow
Probability is used widely
around alphabet. DeepMind and
Google brain and Google
accelerated sciences, product
areas, infrastructure areas use
it for planning
purposes, but it is also used
outside of Google.
Baker
Hughes uses this to predict
anomalies.
For example, anyone who flew out
here
would be happy to know that bhge
uses their prediction to predict
the lifespan of jet engines.
If we had a dataset using a
failing engine that would be a
tragedy.
Using math they get around this
by
modeling models and then trying
to in
the abstract figure out if they
are going to be good models.
The orange boxes use TensorFlow
Probability extensively.
The orange border box is where
they use TensorFlow.
The basic flow is to try to
treat the model itself as a
random available and determine
if it will be a good model on an
otherwise incomplete dataset.
From this they get remarkable
results
and dramatic increases in false
positives and false negatives
over large
datasets in complicated systems.
So the question is who will be
the next success story? Try it
out. It is an open source Python
package built using TensorFlow
that makes it
easy to combine deep learning
with probalistic models.
You can pip install it.
If you are interested in
learning more
about the
bayessian methods, check out
thus  this book.
If you are not a bayesian, that
is OK too. If you are doing
linear aggression, it could
solve the problem on the order
of 30 iterations which can't be
said of standard gradient
dissent.
If you want to find out more,
you can
check out our GitHub repository
where you can find several
Jupyter notebooks. Thanks.
[Applause]
And with that, I would like to
hand it
off to Eugene and Sergio who
will be
talking about reinforcement
learning.
Thank you.
Hello, everyone. How is it
going? Very packed day? Lots of
good stuff? Are you ready for
more? Or not? OK. Good. So my
name is Sergio Guadarrama and I
am a software engineer at Google
brain
and I work in the TF agent
steam.
And I am Eugene Brevdo working
on reinforcement learning.
How many of you remember how you
learned how to walk?
You stumble a little bit, you
try one step, doesn't work, you
lose your balance, you try
again.
When you try to learn something
hard practice you need to try
many times. This is moving the
legs and trying to
learn how to walk.
After learning to try multiple
times, in
this case is  1,000 times, it
falls. It will train a little
longer and then
it is able to walk around and go
from one place to another and
find their way around the room.
You have probably heard about
all the
applications including
recommended
assistance, data --
real robots like that, chemistry
and math and always alpha go
that play Go better than any
human. Now, I have a question
for you.
How many of you have tried to
auto implement an algorithm? I
see quite a bit of hands. Very
good. It is hard.
Yeah. We went through that pain
too. You know, many people who
try get the first prototype
right away. It seems to be
working but then you miss a lot
of different pieces.
All the details have to be
right, everything.
There is a lot of pieces and a
lot of things you need to do. We
suffer through the same problem
at
Google and decided to implement
a library that many people can
use and we are happy to announce
it is available online. You can
go to GitHub and pip install it
and start using it right away.
Hopefully, you will provide
feedback contributions so we can
make it better over time.
Now, where is
TF age NLT
-- agents?
For people new, we have Colabs
and things with documentation
and samples so you can learn
about it. For people that want
to solve the
complex problems, we have
already ways to take their
algorithm and apply it.
For people who are researching
and want
to develop new algorithm
they will not need to build all
the pieces. They can build on
top of it.
You can start doing experiments
right away.
We build on top of the goodies
in TensorFlow 2.0 you saw today.
Tf.keras to build the networks
and tf.functions when you want
thinks to go faster and we make
it mobile and
extensible so you can cherrypick
the pieces you need. For those
who are not ready for the
change yet, we make it
compatible with TensorFlow 1.14.
We go back to the sample of the
little robot trying to work.
This is how the call looks like.
You have it define networks.
An actor distribution network
and a criteriaic and actor.
Assuming we have data collected
we can just train through it.
TF-agents provide a lot of
environments already.
We also provide a
state-of-the-art
algorithms including dqn, and
many others.
There are more coming soon. They
are fully tested with quality
version tests and a speed test
to make things keep working. As
an overview of the system, it
looks like that. On the left
side you have all the collection
aspects and we will have policy
that will interact with
environments and collects on
experience. We probably put in
some replay buffer to work later
and on the right side we have
all the training pipeline. We
are going to write from this
experience and our agent is
going to
learn to improve the policy by
training a neural network. Let's
focus for a little bit on this
environment.
How we define a problem and new
task. Let's take another
example. In this case it is
breakout. The idea is you have
to play this game move the power
left and right and try to break
the bricks on the top. You break
the bricks you get rewards and
the points go up.
You let the ball drop and the
points go down.
The agent refers multiple frames
and it will decide which action
to take and based on that it
will get reward and just loop
again. How this look into the
code is something like this.
You define the specific
specification.
What kind of observation this
environment provides. Any other
information.
Multiple things.
Then the action speckspecs. In
this case left and right but in
many environments we have
multiple actions. And a reset
method because we will play the
game a lot and have to reset the
environment and a step method
that taking an action will
provide a new observation and
give us a reward.
Given that we define the policy,
create the environment, reset
the environment and start
looking over it and start
playing the game. Your policy is
very good you will get a good
score.
To make the learning even
faster, we make these parallel
environments and you can run
these games in parallel multiple
times and wrap in TensorFlow so
it will
go even faster and then do the
same loop again. What happened
in general is like we
don't want to define this policy
by hand.
Let me hand it over to Eugene
who is going to explain how to
learn those policies.
Thank you, Sergio.
Yeah, as Sergio said, I am
giving an example of how you
would interact with the
environment by a policy. We are
going to go into the a little
bit more detail and talk about
how to
train policies to maximize the
rewards.
So kind of going over it again,
policies take observations and
emit parameters of a -- a
distribution over the actions.
In this case, the
observations are an image, there
is an underlying neural network
that converts those images to
the parameter of the
distribution and the policy
emits that distribution or you
might sample from it to actually
take actions.
So, let's talk about networks.
I think you have seen some
variation of this slide over and
over again today.
A network in this case network
used for deep Q learning is
essentially a container for a
bunch of keras layers.
In this case, your inputs go
through a convolutional layer
and so on and so
forth and the final layer emits
logits over the actions you
might take. The core method of
the network is the call. It
takes observations in a state,
possibly an RNN state, and emits
the logits and you update the
state. OK. So let's talk about
policies. First of all, we
provide a large number of
policies. Some of them
specifically tailored to
particular algorithms and
particular
agents but you can also
implement your own. It is useful
to go through that.
A policy takes one or more
networks.
The fundamental method on a
policy is the distribution
method.
This takes the time that is
essentially
containing the observations,
passes that through one or more
networks and emits the
parameters of the output
distribution in this case
logits.
It then returns a tuple of three
things.
The first is an actual
distribution object. Josh spoke
about the probability and here
is this low probability category
called distribution built from
the logits, it emits the next
state possibly containing RNN
state information, and it also
emits site information.
Site information is useful --
side information is useful
perhaps you want to emit
information you want to login
your metrics and that is not the
action, or maybe you want to log
some information that is
necessarily for training later
on so the agent is going
to use that information to
actually train. OK.
So now let's actually talk about
training.
The agent class encompasses the
main ML algorithm and that
includes the training
and reading batches of data and
trajectries to update the neural
network. Here is a simple
example. First, you create a
deep queue learning
agent, you give it a network,
you can access a policy
specifically a collection policy
from that agent, that policy
uses the underlying network that
you passed in, and maybe
performs some
additional work like maybe
performs exploration. It also
logs site information that is
going to be necessary to be able
to train the agent.
The main method on the agent is
called train.
It takes experience in the form
of
batch
trajectories from a replay
buffer. Assuming you have
trained the data and
performed well you might want to
take a policy that provides more
greedy actions and just exploits
and takes the best actions it
thinks are the best and
doesn't log any side
information. That is the plan
and policy.
You can save this to a saved
model and put it into the plain.
For a complete example, here we
have a
deep Q learning network.
It has other arguments
describing what kind of keras
layers to combine.
You build the agent with that
network. Then you get a tf.data
dataset.
In this case, you get it from a
replay buffer object, but you
can get it from
any other dataset that emits the
correct batch trajectory
information and you
iterate over that dataset
calling agent.train to update
the underlying neural networks
that are updated in the
reflected policies. Let's talk a
little bit about collection.
Given a collection policy, it
doesn't
have to be trained, it can have
random parameters, you want to
be able to collect data and we
provide a number of tools for
that, again, if your environment
is something that is in Python
you can wrap it.
The core tool for this is the
driver. Going through that first
you create your batched
environments at the top. Then
you create a replay buffer. In
this case we have a tf.uniform
replay buffer. This is backed by
TensorFlow variables. Then you
create the driver.
The driver accepts the
environment and the collect
policy from the agent and a
number of callbacks. When you
call driver.run what it will do
is it will iterate,
in this case it will take 100
steps
between a policy and
environment, it
will create trajecto
trajectories.
After the buffer finished, you
have 100 more frames of data.
Here is kind of the complete
picture.
Again, you create your
environment, you interact with
that environment to the
driver given a policy, those
interactions get stored in the
replay buffer, the replay buffer
you read from with a tf.
data dataset and then the agent
trains
with batches from that dataset
and
updates the network underlying
the policy.
Here is kind of the set of
commands to do that.
If you look at the bottom, here
is that
loop, you call driver run to
collect data, it stores data in
the replay buffer, and then you
read from the dataset generated
from that replay
buffer and train the agent and
you can iterate this over and
over again.
We have a lot of exciting things
coming up. We have a number of
new agents we are going to
release. C51 and so on.
We are adding support for
contextual bandits, we are going
to release a
number of baselines and as well
as a number of new replay
buffers.
In particular, we are going to
be
releasing some distributed
replay buffers, in the next
couple of quarters, and those
will be used for distributed
collection.
Distributed collection allows
you to parallelize your data
collection across many machines
and be able to maximize
the throughput of your training
URL algorithm that way.
We are working on distributed
training also using TensorFlow
new distribution
strategy API allowing you to
train at a massive scale on many
GPUs and TPUs and
we are adding support for more
environments.
Please check out TF-agents on
GitHub.
We have a number of Colabs, I
think 8-9,
exploring different parts of the
system.
As Sergio said, TF-agents is
built to
solve many real-world problems
and in particular we are
interested in seeing your
problems. For example, we
welcome contributions
for new environments, new RL
algorithms
for those of you out there who
are RL experts. Please come chat
with me or Sergio
after the talks or file an issue
on the GitHub issue tracker.
And let us know what you think.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
[Applause]
And now I would like to pass it
off to
Nick and Yannick who will talk
about TensorFlow.js.
Thanks, guys.
Hey, everybody. My name is Nick
and this is my colleague
Yannick. We are going to talk
about JavaScript and ML.
TensorFlow.js is a library we
launched last year. It is a
library for training and
deploying ML models in the
browser and on node.js. We want
to showcase what you can do
today with a platform and where
we are going. One of the great
parts about the library is there
is really no drivers to install.
If you run it in the browser you
can get out of the box GPU
acceleration.
The browser itself tends to be
interactive and builds great
applications and demos for using
ML.
Privacy is a very important part
to the library. You can run
inference and training locally
on the client which works around
all sorts of privacy issues you
might
have with doing server side
inference or training.
And what can you do today with
the library? We have a
collection of, like, pre-trained
off the shelf models you can use
without any knowledge of ML. We
also have the ability to take
existing Python models and
convert them and run them in
TensorFlow.js.
We also have a full-stack for
training, inference and low
level linear algebra
and that runs in a browser in
node.js.
We also have a bunch of
platforms that JavaScript can
run on outside of just the
browser.
The first thing I want to
showcase is
some of our new off the shelf
models we have launched.
The first one is a bunch of
pre-trained -- or off the shelf
models are a bunch of
pre-trained models.
They are image, audio and text
classification models. The APIs
are all user-friendly.
You don't have to worry about
converting images to tensors.
They are available on MPM and we
have precompiled hosted scripts
a well. We are working on this a
lot in the upcoming year and we
will have pore and more models
as we go forward.
The first model was body pics. I
want to show you how easy it is
to
use this model.
First include the library and
body pics. It is two simple
imports.
The next step is to create an
image
DOM. This is Frank. He is trying
to do something on the couch but
I want to actually load the
model and find body parts on
Frank.
The first thing to do is to load
the body pics model. Just a
simple one-line call. The next
step is to call one of the
methods we expose which is
estimate
person segmentation and I can
pass in a
DOM element.
There is also a bunch of really
easy to use methods for doing
filtering on the image. So I can
take the results of that and
render it directly on there DOM.
It shows head, body, arm and so
on. Another model we launched a
couple
weeks ago is the toxicity model.
To use this model, we will use
the prehosted scripts.
Two lines of code.
I will load the toxicity model
and ask
the model to classify just some
really
lovely text, pretty pg, you
suck, and I will get a result
back as a JavaScript
object that has seven labels we
identify
different types of toxic-type
text and the probabilities and
if it matches.
We also have the ability to take
pre-trained Python models for
run them directly in browsers.
If you have a pre-trained model
trained in Python world we have
a command line tool that makes
it easy to serialize the model
as a JSON object and the weights
and distribute them in a web
format.
We support saveModel, TensorFlow
Hub and keras models.
It supports over 170 and
counting ops and we will be
TensorFlow 2.0 compatible. I
want to walkthrough how simple
it is to use this. I is a Python
model and run it through the
command line tool and I can
easily load that in my
JavaScript application. Very
simple.
I want to hand it off to Yannick
to
walk through the pre-trained
model.
TensorFlow.js allows you to
train in the browser and in
node. The primary tool for this
is the layers
API which is a keras-compatible
API for authoring models.
We are going to take a quick
look at
what TF.js code looks like.
The first step to is import the
library and when working in
node.js you can also use the
node.js bindings which execute
the TensorFlow
operations using native compile
C++ code.
If you are an a system that
supports
kuda, you can import -- cuda --
you can -- this is what creating
a convolutional model for a
classification task looks like.
It is similar to keras code in
Python.
We start by instantiating a
model and add a flat operation
and a dense layer with output
classes.
Similar to Python we use model.
compile and specify loss
function and optimizer and
model.fit is the function that
drives the train loop.
In JavaScript it is an a sync
function
so we want to wait for the
result or to be done.
Once it is done training we can
save the model.
We support saving to a number of
targets both on the client and
server.
And you can use model.
predict to get a result from the
model, finally. Over the past
year, we have also heard
feedback from the community on
ways we
can improve the experience of
training with TensorFlow.js. We
would like to show you progress
we have made.
First up it is tf.data.
It is an  an API for managing
data training. It provides a
whole set of utility functions
for dataset transformation.
Finally, it works with streams
and the lazy evaluation allows
you to work with
data that doesn't fit in memory
which can be quite important.
Let's look at a simple example.
We load up a
CSV file and use the is label
attribute.
For example, in this map
transformation, the price data
has been separated out into that
Y object and the rest of the
features are in the X object.
Once we flattened the data we
can apply typical ML
transformations including
things like shuffling, an ML
best practice, and batting which
will do the
work of creating properly sized
mini batches for training and
know what to pull into memory
when the training loop is
running.
Other things include things like
normalization.
Finally we run the train loop.
Model.fitdataset supports models
and pulls the right stuff into
memory as needed. And that's
tf.data.
So the other area we have been
responding to community feedback
is visualization.
I want to talk about tfjs-vis
which is
model of internals as well as
evaluation
metricsism you can view
internals and evaluation
metrics. First we import the
library and you
should node we provide tfjs-vis
as a separate package.
To visualize training behavior
we can
use this showshow.fitscallbacks
function.
In one line, fit callbacks will
plot the selected metrics.
In this case loss and accuracy
metrics
on the batch end and at the end
of each epoch.
This allows us to adjust
hyperparameters as usual.
You can look at model internals
with show.
model summary and show.layer
summary. Here we see the
architecture of the
model including output shapes of
SARSAR -- various layers.
We see the distribution of
layers in the first
convolutional layers including
statistics like nans and zero
counts which are useful for
debugging models.
We want to finally announce
TensorBoard support in node.js.
You can monitor when using the
TensorBoard layer in node.js. A
single line will generate the
necessary callbacks to write the
methods
to a TensorBoard log file using
this command. Then you can open
in TensorBoard and look at how
your training is going just like
you may be used to. With that, I
am going to hand it back to Nick
to talk about some of the
platforms we execute on.
JavaScript is an interesting
language because it runs in a
lot more places than you think.
There is the traditional browser
front for running JavaScript in
the browser. We all know about
that. Node.
js is a big server-side
solution. Very popular. But
there is also a growing trend
with JavaScript in more places.
One of them is desktop
applications and
electron is a very popular
platform for developing
applications.
Those who have used Spotify or
visual code those are good
examples of electron.
JavaScript is moving into the
mobile space also. I want to
highlight a couple examples
we have seen in the industry on
all four platforms.
First is the browser.
Our friends at Google creative
labs
have built experiments on how
creative tools could be more
accessible to everyone. There is
going to be a great lightning
talk on this and they will talk
about everything they have built
with this project.
Uber has built an in-browser
tool for
model agnostic visualization of
ML performance. They use
TensorFlow.
js for acceleration of their
linear algebra. K means
clustering and so on. They are
also giving a great lightning
talk about how they use
TensorFlow.
js to solve this problem for
their platform. This is all in
browser, again.
Another cool industry example is
Airbnb. Airbnb built an identity
document
detection model that they use as
a full TensorFlow ecosystem
solution. On our Airbnb profile,
if you were to
upload a government-issued ID it
is a very big trust issue. They
built a TensorFlow model to
detect if a profile picture that
you are trying to upload
directly in the client contains
government-issued IDs. They use
this in the browser using
TensorFlow.
js as well as on their mobile
devices for TFLite.
On node.js, a good example of
this being used is clinic
doctor. This is a node.js
performance analysis tool. They
use our node.
js bindings to filter out gc
spikes on
node processes that are running
to give a true accurate CPU
performance benchmark.
On the desktop, our team here at
Google
with magenta and their music
generation
models, have built a series of
desktop plugins for the Ableton
studio. These are full desktop
applications that use the
magenta models and
accelerate them all into the GPU
and desktop applications.
We have a demo at your booth for
how this works.
The cool part is all JavaScript
and GPU
acceleration on the desktop with
no cuda drivers all through the
findings.
Mobile is another interesting
space.
WeChat, for example, is one of
the most popular apps in the
world with over 1
billion total users and a
subapplication platform called
the mini programs. They are
great because it is no-need
install app in advance used on
demand
and has over 1 million apps and
1.5 million developers.
The mini program is built using
JavaScript and makes it easy for
developers to create, deploy and
share on the WeChat platform.
I want to show a demo of a tfjs
models running on WeChat.
I have just a regular iOS device
and I will open WeChat.
Someone shared this tfjs example
and I can load up the
application.
It is running our post net model
and if
I aim it at Yannick here, there
we go,
this is just purely done in
JavaScript
and it is running our off the
shelf mobile model doing about
30 frames a second.
This is all done with the WeChat
JavaScript platform.
platform.
Thank you.
So, all this work over the past
year and the fantastic projects
created by the
community, makes us very excited
to announce TensorFlow.js 1.0
today. It is available now and
we are super excited to see what
the community builds
with it and hopes the API
stability makes it easier going
forward.
We are focused on providing a
stable API you can build
applications on and manage
upgrade easier and bringing
market improvements in
performance particularly on
mobile devices. We will look at
that in a bit more detail. To
look at the update closer, since
announcng TensorFlow.js last
year at the Dev Summit we have
been working on improvements
across a number of platforms.
We see increases of about 1.
4X to 9X in some extreme cases.
This chart shows inference
performance
with a batch size of 1 on mobile
net in Chrome.
It is a mobile image
classification and
we see inference times going
from about
15 milliseconds to about 150
milliseconds on the pixel 2. We
have done performance on the iOS
devices as well so really
excited for you to try this.
What is next for us? Well, we
want to enable you to execute
saved models on our node.js back
end without going through the
conversion process and this will
open up
many more models to serve using
the js.
node stack.
We are always keeping an eye on
browser
acceleration proposals like simd
and WASM.
The browser is only going to get
faster and so will we.
We want to expand the platforms
on which TensorFlow.js can run.
We are working on platforms like
the
Raspberry Pi and other hybrid
mobile platforms that run
JavaScript.
So thanks and for more
information on
the things we talked about, you
can
visit any one of these links.
Thank you.
And last up is Elena to talk
about her
work using machine translation
in the Vatican secret archive.
Thank you, Nick and Yanni.
It is great to be here. Just one
second.
I am excited to be here and to
talk to
you about the In Codice Ratio
project that is going on at Roma
university. To talk to you about
TensorFlow help us
build a model that is able to
transcribe ancient manuscripts.
You can see the polyographers
and archivist and on the left is
the data science team. That is
why I think the name, In Codice
Ratio, reflects us well.
In Latin, it means a known edge
for
transcript
but in Italian it means software
code so it is knowledge through
software.
You might ask
yourselvesyourselves,
what brings polyographer and
archivist
and data scientists together.
They both want to
discover knowledge from big
data.
Historical archives are an
endless
source of important cultural and
historical information. Just to
give you a scale of how large
this information can be, let's
compare
for a second the sides of the
Vatican
secret archive to the height of
Mt. Everest. If you were to take
each shelve of the
Vatican secret archive, you
would get to 85 kilometers tall.
That is about 10 times the size
of Mt. Everest and the content
spans centuries and continents.
There you have examples of
letters
coming from China, from Europe,
from
Africa, and of course from the
Americas.
What is our goal?
To build tools and technology
that enables in general to
perform large scale analysis on
historical archives because
right now the process is
entirely manually. You have to
go there, consult the documents
manually and be able to read the
challenging handwriting and if
you find information that may be
linked to
another collection, you have to
do it all by yourself.
But first, we have to face the
very first challenge and that is
when you are dealing with web
content, for example, if you
want to extract data from the
internet, that is already text.
We said we are dealing with
historical documents and that is
often scans.
Traditionally OCR is fine for
printed text but then you get to
this.
This is a medieval handwriting
and a language nobody uses
anymore.
It is a handwriting nobody is
able to write or read anymore
for that matter.
It is heavily aggregated and you
want to get text out of it. You
might want to train a machine
learning model but then we come
to the second challenge and that
is scalability in the dataset
collection process.
The graph you see there is an
algorithmic scale and it might
show you something you know that
it is known as
the zip flow that tells you that
there
is very few words and most of
the words do not occur that
often. What does that mean for
us?
If we want to collect data at
vocabulary or word level, we
have to
annotate thousands of lines of
text
which means thousands of --
hundreds of pages. Similar
systems do exist. There are
state-of-the-art systems but
most of the polyographer even
when they know of the tools get
discouraged using them because
they say it is not
cost-effective because it can
take up to months or even years
on these
documents to get a transcription
service they will use once or
twice whereas they would like to
do it faster. We asked ourselves
how can we scale on this task?
We decided to go by easier
steps, simpler steps.
The very first things we did was
to select data for single
characters.
This enabled us not to involve
polyographer but people are less
experience.
We built a custom crowd sourcing
platform that worked like capcha
solving.
You see an actual screen there.
The workers were presented with
an image and target and had to
match the target and select the
areas inside the image.
In this way, we were able to
involve more than 500 high
school students and in about two
week's work we made more than
40,000 annotations.
Now we had the data and we
wanted to build a model.
When I started working at the
project, I
was pretty much a beginner in
machine learning and so
TensorFlow helped me put
in practice what I was studying
in thereytheory. It was a great
help that I could rely
on tutorials and the community
and where everything else failed
even the source code.
So, we started experimenting and
we decided to start small first.
We didn't want to overkill.
We wanted the model to fit
exactly our data.
We started small and proceeded
incrementally and in a constant
cycle of tuning hyperparameters
and the best optimizer and
initializers and the number of
layer and the type of layers
and then evaluaing and training
again. Then we used keras which
allowed us to keep the code
spall and readable. This is what
we settled for.
It might look trivial but it
allowed us
to get up to 94% average
accuracy.
Where does this fit in the whole
scheme
of the
transcription center? We have
the input image.
We are relying on over
segmentation and that is a bit
old school but it allows us to
feed the single characters or
combinations of characters
inside of the
classifier which then produces
different transcription
according to a latent
language model which we also
built from publically available
sources. How good do we get?
We get about 65% exact
transcription
and we can get up to 80% if we
consider minor spelling errors
or if the segmentation is
perfect.
If we had perfect segmentation
we could get up to 80%.
We can see it can be more
challenging. What are plans for
the future? We are very excited
about the
integration
integration of TensorFlow and
keras.
What we found out was that
sometimes some were lagging
behind and sometimes
we wanted to get to one part of
the features or from keras or
TensorFlow and we found
ourselves doing lots of -- I
don't know if that is your
experience as well but we found
ourselves doing back and forth
between TensorFlow and keras
and now we get the best of the
two worlds and are very excited
about that. How do we plan to
expand our machine learning
system?
First thing first, we are trying
units that achieved good results
on medical imaging.
We are planning to use them to
get rid
of the segmentation and achieve
the result of classifying
together. Those examples worked
particularly well.
Of course, since there could be
ambiguitywe could do error
correction
and
transcripttranscription. We want
to evolve and move to word
level and even sentence level
annotated
characters, but still our focus
is
calbility and we want to involve
polyographers as little as
possible.
This is generated input from GAN
but we plan to use an encoder to
evolve the
dataset with little human
interaction, like the less we
can.
And in the end this brings us to
use sequence model that will
take full
advantage of the sentence level
context, for example, and could
be able to solve
things that we could not be able
to
solve with single, let's say,
with single character
classification, for example
abbreviation.
Many words occur aggregated in
this
text just like you would text
saying me
too and use 2 the number or for
you and
that is the same with this kind
of manuscripts. That is one
application you could have.
We are planning to use sequence
models to get to a neural model
because so far we have only
experimented with statistics.
And one last thing, I mentioned
the people in the team but there
is so many people I would like
to thank that were not in those
slides.
First of all Simone who should
have
been here but he couldn't make
it.
And then py school of AI and
Luke for
their amazing mentoring and a
high school teacher that
actually allowed us
to involve those students that
work for the platform.
And of course, all the graduate
and undergraduate students that
worked with
us and helped us achieve what we
have achieved and what we plan
to achieve in the future.
And of course, that you can  --
thank you for your attention.
[Applause]
Thank you, Elena. All right.
This is the end of day 1. We
hope you had a great time.
A big thank you to our speakers,
our staff, our crew, and to the
audience
here in Sunnyvale and all around
the world. With that, let's take
the livestream
out with a look at some
highlights.
Hello, everybody.
Right now, right now, before you
leave, there is a survey.
Please, it has been emailed to
you right now. Please do the
survey. This is machine
learning. We need data. No,
seriously, like we can't bring
these events if you can't find
out what you think of them.
Please, please fill out the
survey. Next we have a social
night. Tomorrow we have talks,
breakout
sessions, we have coding, we
have workshops.
Doors open at 8:00 A.M.
and lightning talks start at
9:50.
We will
have breakfast and start
lightning talks. We have
breakout on performance, mobile
and 2.0 and we have an amazing
series of research talks.
Please, please, we will see you
tomorrow.
Go have a drink.
[Applause]